everybody hello hello i can't believe it it's real and it
didn't get silk song i was so surprised i was that was like
my number one fear i was like oh my god i hope it doesn't
get silk song where i cannot fucking even download this game
what is incredible is that this game is actually was 25
gigabytes to download and i've been so used to games being
80 plus gigabytes and taking fucking forever i was very
shocked um anyway i want the one i want to say is that i am
not sponsored by this game so i can say whatever i want um i
think it's because i did not have the best reaction to it
when i the trailer first launched so so i think that's why
they didn't really contact me to sponsor me because i think
like i know all my friends are sponsored to play this game
today for the launch event not all of them but i know some
of my friends they could tell me about this game and but i
think i think my initial reaction to this game was not very
positive but to be fair i was expecting titan fall three to
be fair so so this will be my first reaction my first raw
reaction to this whole game um what else i'm just gonna rip
it right now because I want to know what it is.
This is the most mysterious.
And, like, it's the most mysterious and, like, no info ever
launch I've ever seen for a game like this.
So, it's going to be interesting.
I have no idea what to expect.
I do have a little bit what to expect, but I'll tell you
guys about it when we play the game.
It's like the, I swear, it's such a weird launch.
It's like, it's so weird.
yeah yeah there's not a lot of info going off of this game
also i don't know if a sound guy is a lot but get ready to
balance this oh it has easy anti-cheat it's just like apex
oh my god um who even made this it is x respawn dev so x
apex slash titan fall developers that made this game they
invited a bunch of people over a bunch of fps players over
to check it out and a lot of invited to the event itself um
i won't spoil things until we're in the game um because like
you know you know i don't like obviously like it's not
something i can't tell yet and like jeff was incredibly
cocky um about this whole thing like he was like i'm gonna
prove you guys right you guys gonna have to say so and i
will say like i said if the game is actually really fun and
really good i'll eat my words i'll be like you oh my god i i
i thought i was gonna fall for it again but oh my god it was
actually a decent game i will say i will admit i will admit
fall if it was actually a really good game it was just it
didn't really have the best marketing if i mean to be fair
it didn't have the best marketing turned into like a fucking
amazing marketing because there's so much mystery
surrounding it um there was just so much mystery and like uh
surrounding this whole game and people being like is it even
gonna be alive and then that became the marketing because
people now are like so fucking curious it was just it was
like the craziest marketing strategy and then suddenly
they're like bam we actually invited a bunch of creators to
check this game out i'm like oh my what i was just like wait
a secret creator event was happening as well oh it's a
battle pass free that's cool enemy we're seeing a horse is
really fun too i was just i was concerned about that i was
like i don't know if i want to shoot on a horse all right
i'm in the queue i should boot it up this game faster i'm in
the queue i will be i have very low expectations going in um
but i will um if it's good i will admit fall to it oh i'm in
oh man it does feel very apex slash paladin-y i think it's
the horse it's the horse isn't it all right let's see
apparently um i did ask my friends like which class seemed
the most fun to play but then like i think they went i
forgot i was trying to ask that but they went to bed before
i could um apparently the strongest weapons though is the
the shotgun and the sniper which whatever one is the sniper
i don't know which one it is i assume it's the ranger
they're telling me that shotgun and the ranger was the
strongest weapons in the game oh my god wait 10 out of 10 i
can ride a bear No, I can't Wait, that's fucking sick I can
ride a fucking bear Oh My bro, and a Griffin To pull a bear,
man Um The game already came out And we're, I gotta, I gotta
have an advantage You know?
Yeah Head wall What the fuck?
Oh, rank coming Soon.
If this game is good, I will try And play rank on it Alright
what's what's default dan atticus uh throw a charged spear
that shock nearby continuous damage charges his passive
charge axe release an electrical explosion that damaged
nearby oh my gosh i feel like you guys would have want to
see the let me give you guys the uh yeah let you guys read
the abilities charge axe releases an artificial explosive
that damages all rise into the air and ring lightning spears
who do i want to play okay launches three smoke clouds that
reveals in its wake.
Condor birds.
Oh, this is like Bloodhound.
Send a bird which detects enemies.
Gains a movement reload buff after killing enemies.
Roy to destroy walls.
Bro, this guy fucking is like that, the Titan mode right
here.
Gains, grabs allies, and overshield that absorbs.
Sacrifice down enemy players to charge or to.
Oh, enemy players.
I thought that was like teammates.
Create a spawn point.
Okay, so this is the medic, the support.
Okay, yeah.
defensive um summon mr hulab concussion grenades spirits
appear to give him loot bro what the okay assault is there
only like one oh there's only one support there's like 500
dps players though just ah yes my typical shooter game my
one support and 20 20 dps all right um shift a destructible
it's very very accurate uh no oops all dps ship with
destructive while in the sand temporarily making it throw up
to six killing a player with dagger oh wait this is like
what's your name um that girl in valorant uh enter stealth
mode making sure yourself hidden into enemies that sentence
out uh i don't know which one to play this all they all seem
pretty fun oh it transforms into kaya's inner demon i like
this i maybe i'll try her out Yeah, jet.
Yeah.
Can I even try her out?
Equipped.
Wait, how do I lock her in?
Hello?
I want to play her.
How do I?
Alright.
We gotta learn how to play.
Oh, I guess I can't yet.
I gotta learn how to play first.
Alright.
Okay, now I can actually talk about this.
It's 3v3.
That was the one thing my friends did tell me that I could
get still quick.
It's that uh it is 3v3 it's not 3v3v3v3 it's just 3v3 so
it's very geared towards pre i feel like that's really
geared towards uh pre-mains and not like a very it might not
be a very fun solo queue experience over time right now
because it is launched a lot of people are playing it so um
um yeah i i thought i honestly i personally think that it
would be more fun if there's Or if it's more like 3v3, 3v3,
like it's like bedwars, you know, like constant action.
Like they said it's already constant action with it being
3v3.
Yeah, it's like arenas, basically.
Here we are.
Oh my god.
The worst part is like there's no sense conversion.
Because of how fucking mysterious.
How fucking mysterious this launch was.
I have no.
There's no.
There's no current like sense conversion for this.
Nobody knows.
Nobody knows the sense for this.
It just feels like arenas, I feel it.
Alright, use Mantle to climb the walls.
Alright, I know.
I just called me Flynn.
First steps just ahead.
See what you're made of.
Surprisingly, there is...
I actually asked about this, and there's no tap strafe.
There is bunny hop.
There is bunny hop, though.
There's no tap strafe.
uh let me see if i actually let me add bunny hop right now
um there we go already bound are you sure you want doing so
yes there you go is it lagging a little bit over here kid
let's get this thing started okay don't worry i'll just come
back we know what to do go ahead take some shots he wants me
to take my shots but give me a sec i gotta make sure i'm not
lagging for There you go.
That should be better.
There you go.
That's a fuck.
Okay, this is like a D-Go.
You've got this.
Take a moment.
There you go.
Nice shooting.
Now try it with the scope.
You just let try it with us.
Oh, what?
That's what I've been doing.
You're like, okay, now try it with scope.
I was like, but that's how I've been aiming in this.
where is how do i equip it did he give it to me what the
fuck how do i did he he gave it to me right
oh oh okay it's shift okay there we go all right all right
now try the grenade the grenade i can read guys you guys
know that the grenade
okay okay i was gonna say did i miss all right go to this
one um in terms of like does it feel like how the do i
achieve my weapon though you'll find good weapons but the
rare ones are all right the upgrades evolve longhorn dynasty
yeah that's why guys that's why i do not know fucking gun
names like actual gun names like they give me guns like this
uh uh sure let's try let's try the the gun that looks like
an ak faster reload magazine size stability uh no this is
the movement does not feel like apex it feels a lot it is a
bit clunkier than apex but there is a zip still it's
dangerous out there you can lose yourself or your mate but
folks like us don't quite go away now it feels slow we can
come back with help give it a good all right revive all
right i touched your soul that's all for this place let's go
blow some stuff up shall we i touched your soul how does
that make you feel I just squeezed your soul into existence.
I was like, you ain't dying on me.
You still have to suffer on this world.
If I'm still alive, you're still alive.
There we go.
Now the shop is open.
Step right up.
Trade?
Are you...
Oh, wait.
Okay.
Go harvest some vest.
my god no oh my god it's also deadlock oh my god and oh sue
and dead by daylight oh no it's deadlock and dead by
daylight that's it i'm looking just there we go we got a
farm for upgrades apparently come on back i'm gonna rocket
oh great grab that rocket pick up some ammo too okay and
then a rocket launcher a rocket ammo oh no oh no not
upgrades see those gray walls in the building behind me oh
no all right got it god it's gonna take so long for me to
actually learn this game i can't it's not just It's like you
got heart.
You got you got mine and you got craft You got mine and
craft no
And then you got an upgrade I can't just find guns and be
like Am I trying to use rockets or what break them destroy?
Okay I'm gonna use to finish him off.
Oh, I know Oh my god, this sword walls too time to move on
you say you're a warden let's see what power you've really
got I'll meet you over there yeah there is like a little bit
of bunny hop yeah see like you can tell but there's like a
tiny bunny hop here but I'm buying my weapon swap for it
that power is what makes us special unique I'm not achieve
the weapon, though.
Now's the time to really shine.
Okay.
Go up to those walls and show me what you've got.
Alright.
Destroy three walls using your tactical.
Where is...
Q.
Alright.
Rar.
Gotta let out the bear inside me.
Is there a rocket jump?
That is a good question.
I should have tried that.
There we go.
vigil so desperately needs us now let's put all your weight
down this one let it out all right destroy seven was how
just here all right what the fuck oh my god this oh my bro
fuck this wall i guess holy shit okay fuck this wall well
all right wolf in me raw
Board the airship beast mode activated.
Yeah, like stupid don't need no stupid rocket launch I'm
just gonna let out the fucking bear inside me Baby I'm
praying you tonight In my animal animal, but oh, oh round
two Oh my god, and Rainbow Six Siege!
Guys, I'm afraid I...
It says fortify your base and I'm like, bro, no.
I'm so bad at that.
Oh my god, all right, reinforce.
It is also Siege.
Walk up to a wall to reinforce it with iron.
Right.
Our knocking base...
It's time to get out there and find gear.
Alright, gotta find gear now.
How the...
I need to know how to sheave my weapons, honestly.
I'm, like, really curious.
Charge, aim, switch weapons.
Uh...
I just want to do this.
Obede, cancel.
Yeah, I'm gonna swap.
Change that.
Because I want to...
Is there no sheaving the weapon?
I feel like there is it.
I don't...
see it at all i don't know unless i'm crazy i do not see it
i i actually don't see anything about like about like
fucking making sure my weapon like there's melee but that's
it oh ride my horse yeah okay oh there's no like i guess
like what's it called recoil when i'm shooting it doesn't
look like there's recoil when you're shooting on the horse.
But then it's like, imagine the fucking horse fights that
you have.
Oh yeah, there is definitely not.
Yeah.
Yeah, there is no recoil when you're shooting from your
horse.
Alright, blue armor, hammer charge.
Zipline gun.
What the fuck?
oh my god wait oh it's one ammo it's one bullet and a dream
all right so i can make my own zip like oh my god wait is
this the r9 this is the r9 okay let's see oh my there is the
guns are so easy i will say that you can't really spam
crouch though it's very slow i will say like i will say this
movement is very slow yeah i will say that but like there
this there's no recoil there is no recoil look look it's so
easy to aim with this gun i will say it's very easy to aim
with this fucking gun we like oh my god brothers this is way
too easy
whoa reinforcement like like i could very i don't even know
what my sense is but this is so easy to control all right
let's see rocky launcher oh okay my friends did tell me this
gun is very strong like when it's fully wait what that's
like on the head is oh okay so it has to be lower This is
fully geared.
Oh, is that full auto?
They said the full auto sniper was like the best gun.
So I'm not sure.
That's what they told me.
So I'm not sure if this is the actual full auto.
Alright, let's try.
Let's try the...
Let's try if there's rocket jump.
There's no rocket jump.
Okay, let's see.
Okay, head.
okay i'm trying to see like 140 all right yeah that is
strong if you hit them consistently yeah what we've learned
is that there is no is there fall damage no fall damage all
right that's good to know no fall damage whoops there's no
cooldown oh wait there is there's no cooldown for a horse
mount i mean two It's barely a cooldown for it.
Yeah.
What about grenade jumps?
Alright, let's try.
I don't think there is, but like, I'll humor you guys.
You can sort of tell they're in, but I'll humor you.
Alright.
Then rocket ammo.
What's this?
What gun is this?
I don't like that gun.
Going back to my R9.
Open the inventory?
Alright.
Let's grab one more piece.
Try visiting the trader.
Alright.
Over here, Warden.
Let's get you all armoured up.
Wait, let's see.
Yeah, there's quick scope.
Right next to me.
There is quick scope.
Which is, like, pretty good.
That's good.
Because, like, I remember I heard in Overwatch, they got rid
of quickscoping.
So if you were good at quickscoping, then you can quickscope
for this game.
Yeah.
Is there bullet drop?
That is a good question.
Let's try it out.
This doesn't seem like it's bullet dropped.
There's no bullet drop.
You see this?
My crosser is on the head.
My crosser...
My crosser was on the head.
head.
All right, let's see for this guy.
Yeah, there's no bullet drop.
Okay, I get it.
Now I know why this gun is OP.
Yeah, no.
On the head, it hits.
It fucking hits.
There we go.
There might be like, wait, I think there is, oh no, 65.
Yeah, 65 damage.
There might be, um, what's the word?
Fall, um, though.
I think there's falloff.
There's no bullet drop, but there's falloff.
Because it's 55, 100.
Yeah, so, like, the further it is, damage, there is damage
falloff, but there's no bullet drop.
So, it hits again.
There's falloff damage, yeah.
Yeah.
I mean, that's fair.
I would say that's fair.
But imagine if you had three people with that gun.
Imagine if you had three people There you go.
It'd be like, pop, pop, pop.
Don't stand still.
All right, let's see.
I need, oh, do I need more?
All right, I need more ore.
God damn it.
I'm so bad at this.
I don't play dead by daylight.
Oh, shit.
Oops.
All right.
Can I hit your pet?
Oh, yeah, very close.
All right, I'll buy that then.
It's up, Warden.
Sorry about this.
Or Osu.
Don't play Osu.
Wow!
Sorry about that one, Pet.
Oh.
That if you get taken out like that, the armor you've got on
breaks.
This is why multiple armor sets is a good idea.
What?
He's like invincible!
I have to test it out!
I think you're ready.
Alright, respawn base.
Choose your spawn point and head back to base.
Uh...
I mean, this is base, isn't it?
This is my base.
The storm's forming the shield breaker.
shield breaker all right wonder he likes that part does it
slow down when i okay white pool out
right shield breakers ready i want to oh wait is that it is
that the full auto i don't know which one's the full auto is
it that's the what is this
Yeah, is this an auto-full...
Is this an auto-sniper?
No?
A semi-auto.
Guys, I don't know anything about guns.
I would assume like this...
I don't know which one is the full-auto sniper.
Guys, I just know about make-believe guns.
I don't know anything about real guns.
I just know the fantasy guns.
Alright.
I got the shield breaker.
Now take the shield breaker to the enemy base.
Wee!
Oh, I thought I could ride the zip line with my horse.
Rack-a-kaka-kaka-kaka equals...
Okay.
Alright, that understood.
I want to see if there's any guns I haven't tried yet.
Paladins.
I haven't tried this yet.
I don't like that gun.
I wish, like, I could just try with...
I guess you can when...
Oh, is there items in these barrels, though?
I want to know.
No items in these barrels.
Okay.
I just want to know, like, what can I loot and what can't I
loot?
Alright.
Plant the shield breaker.
Oh my god, it's like Valorant!
Everything.
Oh my god, I'm planting.
I'm planting, guys.
I'm planting.
Holy fuck!
I summoned a giant tank.
Guys, I summoned...
Don't worry guys, I got this I planted a giant fucking tank
We got this Wakanda I called up my buddy Wakanda To Chala to
help me out
Yeah, we're sieging Let's finish the job My god We're
sieging right now You're looking for generators to destroy.
Oh my god.
We're dead by daylight now.
We're dead by daylighting
Okay, all right That mate is the beating heart of the base.
All right.
I'm I'm I'm dead by daylight.
I got get the generators I'm planning I'm planning guys I'm
planning cover me
Well, thank you for this welcome the tomato farm welcome
welcome welcome Oh my god.
Oh my god.
It's Valorant.
I'm planning and planning guys.
I'm planning All right monster.
Okay, there you go.
It's the smash pros of shooters Guys guys I'm planning I'm
planning guys cover me.
I'm planning And then oh my god then you have to hold the
air and be like don't stop I'm in.
Okay, now I see why this is geared for pre-mains.
Now I understand now.
Don't worry guys, I'm covering,
I'm covering.
All right.
Yay!
I have no
idea what solo mode.
I feel like I'm going to get yelled at a lot.
Watch the video.
Okay, let me see what this video is before we watch it.
What do you mean watch the video for advanced tips?
Oh, okay.
There you go.
I thought it was going to pop me up to YouTube.
Advanced briefing time.
Okay, I'm going through my HR training.
I'm going to HR training right now, guys.
I'm like, workflow.
Yeah, I got hires.
suits your unique skills and tactics now once you've settled
into a base the defensive phase will begin all right the
defensive phase here you'll have a short window to change
okay oh my god this is like arena this actually is like
arena important they're usually found deep inside surrounded
by destructive This is the siege part.
Use your wall reinforcements to protect those generators.
That's the easiest place to start securing your base.
When the dome unlocks, I'll give you the signal and we're
off.
Oh my god, the bear's so cool, though.
The bear's so fucking cool.
Phase one, gear up.
Phase two, intercept.
And lastly, phase three, raid.
basically gathering armor and upgrading your weapons first
so it's actually whoever gets the sword force scattered
around loot all the resources you can before charging into a
fight don't forget to harvest oh yeah it's like the pre-show
at Disney Reds now we're minecrafting we're mining and
crafting once you have the shield breaker rally up your team
and ride out to the enemy base this marks the beginning of
phase two intercept in the intercept phase whoever has the
shield breaker will be trying to ride with it to the
opposing base and break in okay the team tries to stop them
again teamwork is invaluable stick together bro that gun
looks strong oh wait I could jump fast with my okay that's
sick that's looking sick if you do you will drop the shield
breaker and But if no one plants before it's platoon, it's
rainmaker shield breaker rainmaker.
That's the splatoon portion It's the splatoon part It's the
rainmaker And try not to let our clock run out It's also
splatoon To the nearest base for zero damage And the raid
will begin the splatoon phase During a raid, you'll need to
work together to successfully...
This game has everything, guys.
Maybe Jett is right.
Oh, that's...
Those players are so shit, man.
Wait, if I have the what?
Be smart.
Plan with your team.
Coordinate and unite those powers for devastating effect.
Oh, my God.
That's actually, like, Jett.
I'm actually really bad at project out, though.
Oh, my God.
Wait, that's...
Wait, that looks like hit-scatter.
Look on mastering these tips and you will become a true
warden of high guard.
I'm gonna become the true warden of high guard.
Where's the marble rival?
See, this is the best part about not being sponsored.
I can just name out random games and they'll be like, they
won't be mad at me.
Except I'm not, I'm not, I'm playing this for free.
I'm actually, I'm just like you guys.
I'm playing this for fucking free right now.
all right all right i don't know the twirling knife thing
seemed really hard maybe i wonder if like all right let's
see creates this i'm gonna try i'm gonna try the summons a
large that throws smaller explosive spirits at way actually
that shit looks sick who launches concussion grenades at
enemies well i'm gonna i feel like people who are like
wraith coated would play scarlet she sees I feel like.
And then Una looks cool as hell.
I want to go to Fire and Range.
I want to check them out.
How am I finding a match in Fire and Range?
It's just me.
Okay, there we go.
I was going to say, it's literally only me in the Fire and
Range.
What match are you trying to find for me?
I feel like Una is, like not Una, whoever the fucking girl,
this girl is with the stealth mode feels very rave-coded.
rave shit.
Oh my god, I'm just trying to go to the fire range.
Like, let me in.
Alright.
We don't know, I don't fucking know, smugglers then.
Oh my god.
Wait, what?
Did I not queue up fire range?
Oh, I can I can queue.
Oh, it's like my own custom fire range.
I see.
How do I swap?
beast's job is to survive.
How do I swap heroes?
What the fuck?
Customize range, change warden.
There you go, change warden.
Okay.
There's no quick set for it, it feels like.
Alright.
Let's see.
Let's see her moves.
Disappear!
Alright.
That's her disappearing.
Oh, so she's like literally not literally disappear.
All right.
E.
I'm pressing E.
Oh, doors on me close when the raid starts.
What the fuck?
All right, customized range.
Let's make this hard for you.
I wanted...
Okay, I do want to max out my ult.
Where the fuck is the ult max out?
Can I not max it out?
Do I actually have to wait?
Oh my god.
It says E.
Oh.
It says E!
What do you mean?
I'm pressing E, guys.
I swear to God, I am actually pressing E.
But there is no, like, way to get your ult really fast,
which...
Like, how the fuck it lets me...
There is more options.
Where is my more options?
I don't understand.
Where's my more options?
All right, change loadout.
Marksman weapons.
Oh, it has...
Is it this?
What's big rig?
Holy shit, what the fuck is big rig?
Like, the fuck is a big rig.
Oh, wait.
That's like the...
What is that gun in Valorant?
That one gun in Valorant.
We all know that gun.
Okay, I can't hurt myself.
okay
that you know what I'm talking about that one the Odin this
is literally the Odin right now big rig alright so people
are telling me that shotgun is OP so let's try it oh wait
there's like a small boost when I get off okay when I get
off the horse that's cool alright let's try oh shit sorry oh
shit sorry oh yeah no the shotgun's insanely strong no it
just takes fucking forever to reload no yeah no it's like
fortnite it actually is like fortnite like the shotgun power
yeah i understand if you like if you can get the head then
it'd be like crazy i will say reloading is the bitch i might
i think my sense It's still a little too high.
I'm going to grab it down a little.
It feels a little too high.
You can't crouch spam in this game, which I don't know how I
feel.
But it's definitely...
Yeah, very heavy damage.
So if you're like a Fortnite player, you might actually be
really good at this game.
Because I was told...
Like, this is actually pretty...
That's a two-shot.
It's actually a two-shot if you're close.
Obviously, the further you are.
I mean, but I'm feeling like a peacekeeper.
Like, yeah.
There is a...
There is fallout here.
So...
It is strong, though.
I will say the peacekeeper, sorry.
The Kraken is very hard to look at us.
Like, what is it called?
The Kraken.
You can't crouch spam on this.
The crouch is so slow.
It's very, very slow.
Do I gain all charge from shooting at all?
No, I don't.
How do I gain all charge then?
It's just passive?
It feels like it's just passive.
I wonder.
I'm releasing.
Missing the Kraken.
Ah!
Yeah, no, the tea bagging is very slow.
There's no...
You can't fucking...
I don't like that I can't test out my ult.
There must...
I feel like there should be a way to, like, test out the
ult.
That's, like, the one...
My current criticism so far is that I just...
I want to test it out.
I want to know what my ult is.
But, like...
But, like, it's not giving me the opportunity.
option too yeah oh yeah no the ease i think the ease setting
i think they bugged it out because i'm pressing e and it
doesn't give me anything apparently i mean like my e is not
unbounded i have e up i mean i don't it's not yes the e is
bounded so uh oh wait there's emote's nice okay wait i
should all right i'm gonna do that here and then where's my
melee Okay, melee.
Ultimate power.
Oh, yeah, that's the summoning.
Yeah.
I am holding it.
I did try.
I tried holding it.
It didn't work.
But we're passively recharging our thing right now.
Yeah, I just want to see...
I want to see...
Like, her alt.
That's all I want to know.
Like, please.
Please, sir.
Can I check her alt out?
It's very...
easy to aim in this game like so far from my like so far
from me testing out all the guns it seems very easy to like
aim but i'm not but that's just my initial opinion on it so
like i'm not sure if it actually it actually is but it feels
very easy aimable um let me try this and then Oh, longhorn.
Have I tried this yet?
This feels more like an...
Actually, this feels like a R9, too.
Was this...
Yeah, this feels...
This is the R9 for me.
Oh, wait.
Alt's ready?
Alright, let's try it.
Alt is ready.
Oh, wait.
That's not the alt.
That's stealth mode.
Who's the alt button again?
Fuck.
It doesn't even tell me.
sorry i went i went straight to my other okay ultimate is it
ultimate power is it there's no way that's four i'm so used
to using q oh my god it is four okay oh my god yeah it's jet
yeah it's it's jet
yeah what are the abilities when it was uh when if we're
Apex?
Yeah, no, that's literally Jets.
Like, in Apex.
What was... I don't know what was Q.
What was her... What was the abilities for...
Oh, reloading ammo fills up.
Does it?
No, it doesn't.
Oh, oh, refill!
Oh!
This...
Okay, that's all that's what you mean.
Oh, okay.
That's that's weird.
That's so weird.
But what was okay?
It was What was the ability for Apex because I know a apex
is all is Q and then there was a billy button but I forgot
what it is on the top of my head I would remember when I'm
on apex, but right now I'm not I'm on I'm on Uh Overguard
not overguard high guard Z okay Z All right I'm on oh,
sorry.
Hi guy.
All right, let's try Uma out.
All right, Q Time to pick a fight you weird asshole.
Is he gonna shoot?
I guess he's like a little minion.
Stand watch here.
Oh Wait, what the fuck that bro?
I'm bringing my own little minions to the fight All right,
well not the world All right, let's try your ult out What is
this?
Oh my god, I'm literally a necromancer.
Oh my god.
I'm literally a necromancer.
Yeah, I'm my own little minions bring my kids and my And my
college son the workday
Okay, so that's her ability.
All right, what are the others?
All right We try it here.
Okay, what's this?
Send out a bird where Scans launched three clouds.
Oh, so this is her recon.
Okay, recon.
He'll be like, tell me where the enemies are.
It's like me sending my Raven out in Apex.
Picking up nothing.
All right, but how far is the range?
It's not that.
It's like she's just fucking closing a circle.
I wish I could tell what the range is for the Eagle.
But...
All right.
My ultimate's ready.
holy shit I'm setting smokes out I'm saying smokes up breach
breach breach plant the bomb plant the bomb in the smoke
guys but breach breach breach got plant that bomb there all
is smokes yeah I got the line up guys I got the line up
everyone all right is that really lock yet that reveals
enemies within its wake okay literally i can literally just
smoke the um crazy strong yeah i'm i'm practicing my cons
guys guys preach preach all right throw a char spear i think
that shit is op rise and rain lightning spears that do heavy
damage that shit looks OP as hell.
Alright, yeah, like...
Oh, wait.
Fucking... I need to figure out the aim with this though.
Like, I'm like, how the fuck?
Okay.
What the...
There's, there's like a...
So, you see how I'm throwing... That's the cross here?
It goes higher.
So it's so weird.
It's actually weird.
It's higher than what it should be.
What it's... What it's said in the thing.
okay and then oh my god i'm the god of thunder okay i wonder
if it's easy to shoot him down i feel like i feel like it's
very easy to shoot this man down if we all just look at him
i i don't know if i'm op but like i wonder if like if i
still have my hp so far yeah everyone just has to look feel
like he's a giant.
His damage is insane, though.
It looks sick.
It looks fucking... I could try here.
Wait, let's see.
But what if they don't know where I am?
You're so right.
What if I do it from here?
Let's see.
Oh my god.
Keep pressing here.
Wait, I can... Wait, what if?
Wait, I have an idea.
Wait, what if?
Wait, how far does this go?
Oh my god, wait, that hits!
Wait!
From the far!
That's crazy!
What?
I see the vision.
Wait, I see the fucking vision.
Wait, I can snipe rocket, like, missile incoming.
I'm setting a fucking...
I have your location.
Like, my teammate will be like, It's he's over here!
He's over here!
I'm like...
I'm like, target, locked.
Boom!
Artillery strike.
I do not think there was damage fallout to that.
That hit, like, a hundred.
Yeah.
From downtown.
The drones are coming.
Alright, who is him?
He repairs broken walls.
Oh!
That's...
What's her name?
The guy, the girl that repairs doors creates an ice wall.
All right.
I literally, it's like two apex characters in one.
Yeah, she's like, uh, no, no, like.
Oh, yeah, that's May's ice wall.
But like, I meant the apex character where she can reinforce
the walls.
I forgot what her name is.
Wait, what the fuck?
How?
Okay, these ices are very, okay, I will say they are very,
easy it's catalyst yeah catalyst and me because she like he
can reinforce the walls too they are very easy to break
though these walls are not strong as hell all right now i'm
letting the beast out
what the fuck what the fuck what the fuck okay that's okay
that's a thousand oh my god and i have a shield i've just
walked on him i'm like what who should i do bro okay one
okay i think this guy is op this guy is op jesus christ what
do you know smash one minute of smash bro okay the fact that
it did 1k damage is very concerning.
I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
Wait, this was, y'all, all the way up.
He is...
No, no, I just didn't start running.
No, I was just casually walking.
I can actually run in this form.
He's walking slowly towards me.
You know, like, in, like, horror films, you're like, oh,
thank God, he could just slowly walk to you and then he just
starts fucking running and you're like wait you're not
supposed to do that um okay this says over shield and
creates a spawn for it okay this one is just this is the
only support character so i just give people over shield i i
mean like the souls of the fallen fortify you well does that
mean i have to actually be able it i have to be able to aim
the overshield okay all right take this so long okay oh no i
could just throw oh i throw it on the ground and you can
just pick it up oh okay all right that's like kobe i can you
just pick it up okay that's good that's good i was gonna be
like oh my god i have to aim my fucking overshield too but
you can just pick it up all right and then her all is she
just creates it's not really anything you get it's like you
literally find it i think it's like you find the sword and
then you throw like your spawn i'm pretty sure like that's
how you do it yeah so you're like all right um you you see
the sword to do the sword break or what i'm sorry there's so
many terms you do the sword break to grab the sword and
you're like guys i got the spawn go in go go go go yeah come
get your arm yeah i would think i don't know how long last
for it though it doesn't say how long this lasts for um but
i feel like that's how you play that's the spawn point all
right last character what is this guy i think i'm gonna try
i might actually try kai bro i might actually try him
because that's the fucking kai's inner demon like what the
fuck the thousand damage is insane i I have I can't I have
to admit a thousand plus damage when ice hogs ice hogs all
run I'm like thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you wait what was this I didn't read it there's me send in a
cassette cascading wave of molten rain down fire okay so
that's Bangalore right there okay and then okay so that's
the phoenix ability all right so he's not taking damage I 34
second cooldown holy shit all right oh my okay okay here
yeah so this is oh no this is your bro turtle yeah give me a
okay it's not landing it doesn't do a lot of damage i will
say it doesn't feel like it does a lot i wonder if i can if
i hurt myself too i'm gonna try it it feels like a lot
Wait, does it?
No, it hurts these guys.
Okay, I was gonna say, I swear to God, is there friendly
fire in my own goddamn oven when I'm fucking...
He feels garbage, but maybe, like, in-game, it's better,
but, like, his cooldown sucks.
34, like...
34 seconds?
That shit is long.
Yeah.
He feels...
Alright, let's actually play a game.
Leave match.
Alright, let's see what I get yelled at.
Oh, he's got...
What?
I don't...
No!
I just left the training grounds, and they're like, alright,
that's enough for you.
You gotta go back in line.
You gotta go back in line now.
I wanted to play a game, for real.
Let's check out the characters.
Alright, let me grab water real quick while we're waiting in
Login Q.
Okay.
I can't believe I can't believe they kicked me out I should
have stayed I should have stayed in the training grounds and
just never played a game I guess I guess I I should have I
should have stayed there and just looking out that was my
gameplay for the day yeah I high-guarded too hard
They are taking like aspects of other games to create this.
I will say from the PR, from the HR video, I watched the
training video that we watched together.
The game mode, I mean, it's sort of like arena, but not
really.
It's like arena, but like we're sieging.
We're breaching.
All right.
How long is the log?
How long is the login queue, guys?
for it or is it i can't believe it i think it's just like
too many people are on right now it's 3v3 it's 3v3 my cue
was a while oh no i just i just wanted to check out the
characters individually no i was in the i was in the
training grounds earlier just checking each character out
and their abilities and everything.
For now, it seems like Kai, the Ice Hulk, is the strongest.
Because, like, 1,000 damage for...
Like, what the fuck?
That's insane!
1,000...
Bro, the fucking fire guy sends out his ult, and it lasts,
like, five seconds.
Hulk Man can be in Hulk mode for a thousand...
For, like, one minute.
And his ult does 1,000 damage.
Like, 1,000 AOE.
Like, that seems so fucking broken.
Yeah, the wall is pretty ass.
Because all this goes goddamn crazy, I will say.
He seems pretty fucking OP for shit.
All right, now I can.
But yes, it is 3V, 3V, 3.
So I'm going ice mode.
All right, head, wall, war chest, challenges.
I assume, like, these are just stuff you can do.
Okay, so that's, like, a battle.
type deal and then there's the shop all right let's try it
out let's let's go right in let's high guard it it's high
guard time i'm gonna go as a hulk
okay i'm gonna go like like turn around
they wouldn't let me kill for some reason they're like stop
really didn't want me to go get into the game i don't know
why
all right all right i'm gonna high guard my first match i
hope i don't get yelled at but let's see how did doki get in
like three minutes behind me waiting for 30 fiber baby
they're like she got the fiber i will not that's right it's
part of who i am kying it out i'm i'm gonna kai out don't
make me angry not a streamer privilege bro i can't believe
people i've made my waiting room tweet and they're like why
didn't you put hashtag ad i was like what i i'm just putting
my waiting room i'm freaking i'm i'm i wish i got sponsored
but i definitely was did not have a positive reaction during
the game But we're literally more like, we know you got
sponsored for this.
Bro, oh no!
He already has a bear!
Base will unlock soon.
Stock up.
Reinforce the walls.
Okay, don't worry.
Oh, wait.
Wait, I can change my loadout.
Wait, okay, I want to do shotgun.
Let's do shotgun ranger.
Wait, I belong.
Actually, wait, actually, shotgun...
um maybe ranger and then what was it was vanguard the r9 or
was it dana's oh wait no it's viper i shout out to vanguard
i feel like vanguard might be better and uh oh yeah ranger
there you go okay don't worry guys i shall reinforce all
right we're we're breaching we're sieging we're sieging oh
how do i close the window
Do we reinforced everything?
I assume we did.
Alright, don't worry, guys.
Let's go.
We're right.
Oh my god, bro, that's so sick.
I should have... I wish...
Oh my god, I'm like a stupid horse and everyone has... They
have a bear.
Do we have to go together as a team?
Because I am not.
Oh shit.
Maybe I should have came with my team.
well.
Okay, I don't like the coaster.
Maybe it would have been smarter to walk with my team.
If I get ganked, I'm fucked.
I'm gonna go with them.
I'm a little scared.
I don't know where the fuck the bases are or anything.
Don't worry, I have my guns out.
Hello.
Ooh.
Wait, the Kraken.
Wasn't that the that's a shotgun oh that's a good ass
shotgun but i want to keep my other gun i want to keep the
vanguard because it feels like my type of aim type deal wait
i hear a sniper all right yeah i know like the fucking
make-believe fantasy guns fuck with me this is why i don't
know my goddamn guns these goddamn make-believe guns all
right osu Okay.
There we go.
I'm mining, I'm crafting, I'm mining and crafting.
I have to find the sword.
I'm so scared.
I feel like, I don't know, people like play together or like
separate.
I feel like I'm just gonna play with my team for now.
I'm mining away, mining.
God damn it.
There we go.
Oh shit!
Let's go here, crew.
The shield breaker is forming at the dungeons.
Oh!
The shield breaker is over there.
Wait, they're farming!
They're farming!
The shield breaker will be forming soon.
Are they not gonna...
Wait, what the fuck are they...
What are they trying to do here?
But...
What?
Oh my god, so confused what their plan is all right was
there my type of guns in here there's a goddamn hammer i saw
us all crackings because we have to fight at the shield
breaker soon my god like i don't hear anyone i'm so paranoid
i'm so paranoid right now i'm so paranoid What can I get
you?
Shield breakers ready.
It's go time group.
The shield breakers and enemy has Ready?
Okay, we definitely We were definitely too Oh my god, he has
the rainmaker.
We're too passive.
Okay, it's over here.
We're way too passive.
Okay, where is he?
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Wait.
Wait, what the fuck?
I definitely do not like...
Oh my god.
Okay, there we go.
Oh, it's a recharge.
It's a fucking recharge.
Okay.
Putting a wall for myself.
Alright.
I need to adjust my sense.
This is not my sense, for real.
Go and make a mess, little one.
We went that way.
I'll help my guy.
There you go.
Oh shit.
I'm gonna go over.
Wait, what?
Hello?
What?
That actually, oh my god.
I'm so mad.
I actually could have killed him.
I'm so...
What the fuck?
I got...
What the fuck was that?
I'm mad.
I'm actually mad because like, I could have...
100% kill this guy.
Like, this guy was not good.
This guy was trash.
This guy was actually trash.
I could have killed him.
I'm so sad.
He actually got, like, so lucky.
I hide guy too hard.
This way, friends.
I can't see him.
Oh my god, there he is.
Oh my god, please don't die.
Don't die, guys.
Okay, I think I know how it's gonna be hard.
What the fuck?
There we go.
I need a heal.
Jesus Christ.
I need a regen.
Heals real quick.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay.
God damn it!
They've got the shield breaker.
me oh my god I believe in him I believe in him I believe
respawn lock does that mean I can I'm still so sad like I
I'm so sad that like oh no he's they're breaching they're
breaching they're breaching okay now I know okay or are they
oh my Here they are.
Oh, I can't do shit here.
Oh my god, they're coming over.
Ah, fucking stupid.
You're so goddamn stupid.
Rush him, rush him.
Oh my god.
Where is he?
He's right here.
Wait, what?
Oh my god.
I got the one.
They respawned too.
I fucking Ah, they respawned.
I'm stupid.
They fucking respawned so fast.
I didn't realize that's how fast the respawn rate is.
Yeah.
I didn't realize.
There's such a fast respawn.
Holy shit.
That respawn is so goddamn fast.
I'm still so sad.
I should have won that.
I now know why his shotgun is so goddamn strong.
An enemy bomb is counting down.
Diffuse it.
Where is...
I can fear him.
Oh my god, it's like below me.
I don't know where they are.
Oh my god.
Scanning coming.
Holy shit!
This is a 1v3.
Ah!
First last.
That's insane.
I've got to respawn like on their base.
Yeah, they came back so fucking fast.
That's insane how fast they come back.
Also, my ult took so long.
I wonder just because I died, I wonder.
Is it because I died that it's like...
Okay, I got a fucking...
Oh, shit.
Yeah, no, sniper just wasn't it for me.
I'm also like white armor right now.
I'm fucking white armor.
Where the fuck is the last guy?
Their siege tower is done.
Now let's clear him out.
Oh my god.
It feels like league when it comes to like the sieging part.
Yeah.
Because now that we defended it.
They got us team.
Let's ready ourselves for the next one.
One out of three.
Okay.
Let's repair.
Alright.
Repair time.
Don't worry.
I'm fucking repairing the wall.
It's like yeah.
Let's reinforce.
Okay.
So.
So this does feel a little bit like league in terms of like
the back and forth.
Definitely armor.
Purple helmet.
I'm not a fan of.
I don't know if I'm a fan of this.
Yeah.
I'm still so mad because I could have fucking won that first
initial fight.
That makes me so mad because like if I didn't lag out, I win
that one fight.
one 100 percent i'm gonna swap oh my god okay never mind
that's a purple ranger i just not have a chance to fucking
not a chance to like fucking use my sniper all right we're
gonna loot real quick van guard all right
Actually, I'm gonna buy it.
Get one of them.
Yeah.
Alright.
Yeah, these matches are long.
I guess unless you're like...
Are you fucking here already?
Alright.
I almost have ult, though.
Who shot him?
Where did they shoot me from?
Oh, I hear them.
hearing to my left oh my god he's crazy why would you just
walk into that
you're insane for that bro oh
my god wait this guy can aim actually shield breakers
forming at the throne room marked it wait i hear someone
coming closer to me
all right all right i vote though i'm fucking out for this
that's i'm going i'm going ice hulk mode actually i'll save
it i'm gonna save it for if they breach us the audio is very
loud i will say i don't know if i like this sniper like
compared to like if i i feel like i have a shotgun this
would be easier honestly what what
I hear him, he's close.
Alright.
I don't get hurt from this.
I actually do.
Wait, what?
That's it.
There's no way.
There's no way I saw.
Oh my god, there's no fucking way.
What do you mean?
This doesn't do a thousand.
What?
It doesn't do a thousand in the end?
What was the point of the training ground?
What was the point?
The training ground showed a thousand.
I got scammed.
I got scammed so hard.
Holy shit.
That is actually such a fucking scam.
The guy had arm in the training ground.
It was a thousand with armor.
What a fucking scam.
I'm going Uma.
going umma that is actually a goddamn scam yeah now the
other else look better i was gonna say like if i do a
thousand damage like that shit is that shit is op and then
just to find out that it's not even a thousand in the match
oh my god there you go reloading taking some damage oh i
wanted i was cocky i thought i could kill him i thought i
could kill him 10 hits critical i thought he was so low he's
not that low it's so hard to gauge the hp it's so hard to
gauge the hp of people so i keep thinking like oh he's low
yeah i definitely need a shotgun shotgun is so op
I'm like, I feel like I'm understanding it a bit more.
I'm definitely understanding this a bit more though, for
real.
Not my sense.
This is not my sense though.
Come on, go to it.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
I'm re-genning, I'm re-genning my HP.
I need to find my sense for this goddamn shit for Shreel.
I'm not a huge fan.
All right.
Got him?
I don't know if it's like too fast, if it's like too fast or
not.
Yeah, these guys can aim.
I'm still so mad.
I could.
Planting a thumper charge.
Planting a thumper charge?
I'm freaking...
I'm breaching now for real I'm breaching oh my god they're
around me aren't they
holy fuck there's a guy behind me he's just oh man he's
right behind me isn't he I know I can't get the shoddy
though wait are you respawned so what the fuck wait you
respawned outside that's so okay I understand no wonder I
was like how are they here so fast you literally respawn
like in their base are you fucking yeah I'm not living that
my teammates like over here yeah I mean it's not that long
to me I don't find it that long.
Oh, raid ending soon.
You have six lives for that respawn, though?
Oh, raid is ending soon.
Oh, out of attack.
Oh, so it, like, just tells you how many lives you get.
Oh, oh my god, I could have botched shit too.
Oh my god, there's bi-phases during your raid.
There's fucking bi-phases.
Oh my god.
This game is...
This game is complicated.
It does take a lot to learn.
Um...
I remember reading the thing and they said that it takes a
while to learn this game mode.
And I understand now.
I want to get rid of my ranger.
Use this time wisely.
Oh my god, the dynasty armor level 4.
Okay, you can buy armor during all of that.
Alright, I'm looking...
Yeah.
No, it's literally just 3v3.
Yeah, this game takes a while.
Like, I'm, like, figuring things out.
Like, the more times I die.
Also, Hulk...
Hulk mode is not good.
Like, I feel like I got lied to.
I feel like...
I feel like I fucking got lied to.
I got scammed.
On the training ground, it was, like, a thousand damage.
I was like, Jesus Christ, what the fuck?
That is insane.
And then, in the end, it, like, it wasn't even actually
that.
Damn, we're having a rocket launcher.
What the fuck?
Yeah, hell yeah.
Give me...
Yeah.
The 1k damage scammed me.
I feel like this seems like a pre-made, not gonna lie.
Like, those guys are so coordinated.
They, like, literally are...
They feel really coordinated.
But now I also know that they respawned next to me after I
killed two.
I was like, what the fuck?
I know a lot of people are pre-mining, so I don't know.
It can always be a possibility.
One second.
Do I can grab it, or do you think I'm going to get fucked
up?
The footsteps are loud as hell, though, I will say.
Enemy spotted.
Grenade out.
I'm out.
Let's ride.
Oh, yeah.
I got...
I don't think I can grab the loot.
I don't think so.
I think they're just chilling here.
The shield breakers forming.
Yeah, I'm gonna go to the shield breaker.
And they went to grab the good loot too, which sucks.
Oh my god.
I have to run.
I can't believe they're all there, too.
Fucking nerds.
Actual nerds.
Walking together as a team.
Oh, I left my guy.
Sorry, buddy, buddy.
They're coming over to my guy.
I'm going to come over.
This sucks.
This guy's actually is here.
Oh, my God.
Fucking course they pass through the moment I look away.
This always happens.
I can't believe it.
Shield breakers ready, don't let the enemy planted or it's
over.
Are you serious?
Oh my god, he flanked!
Oh my god, Dr. Christie!
Oh, he flanked me.
Oh, I got flanked hard!
Are you serious?
Bro, these guys, they have to be calming.
They have to be calming, yeah.
Yeah.
These guys, they can flank the shit out of me.
I'm gonna try and use the longhorn.
We gotta play together, guys.
I don't know.
I feel like I don't know which this guy is strong.
What the fuck?
Why is my horse so now?
Do I want to go back?
Oh, okay.
I mean, I'm not gonna fight 1v3.
I think it's more...
It's definitely more fun as a pre-made, for sure.
think this is this is definitely not oh my god oh my god I
fucked up the wall are you fucking kidding me I could
teleport the base what oh what I was gonna say I could
teleport back like
yeah no solo queue is rough I have my initial thoughts if
you have a pre-made I can see this fun yeah spawns are
locking soon only a few seconds before overtime this is
definitely a play with friends i will agree i'm back you can
trust me let's do this i don't know bro this longhorn sucks
what the fuck we lost this location
i think if i have a pre-made i think this game would be very
very fun i think the lack of pre-mate also i was a garbage
character too i would say the games are a lot i oh it's not
a bit oh my god i was in the barrier like i said like are
you okay every game apparently every game kicks you out of
the you have to rejoin the queue i guess like day two it
would be different pre-mades it's like if it's 3v3 like they
i know a lot of like streamers are getting into stacks for
this to like to like sell the experience you know I felt
like I was playing against the stack I will say I did feel
like I was playing against the stack because they were like
so coordinated but I could be wrong but they definitely this
was not their first game because they knew what the fuck
they were doing uh yeah yeah um but I saw a lot of streamers
we're like oh we're gonna come in with a stack to play this
or they're definitely calming because they knew where the
fuck I was all the time um and the game does feel very long
for it's not a there's not a fun solo queue experience i
will say this the time to kill is so fast um it's so fast
that you know it's very hard for outplayability if you just
run into people because there's not really a lot of places
to hide um i don't feel i don't think there's like a lot of
places to hide to like you know in apex there's like you can
like bounce around different areas if you're um if you're
like um solo queue and stuff so it's easier to like uh
easier to like counter things but for this if you get run up
you're just dead
so i think maybe the rave girl might be better because i can
just go invisible and stuff it's very open it is very open
in general that's how i feel but i got scammed i got scammed
off of this guy.
I was like, bro, his ult seems so insane.
And then, in the end, it...
That shit was a goddamn fucking lie, for sure.
Like...
He was a goddamn lie.
I'm gonna try... I don't know, should I try Scarlet?
Shift the destructive wall into sand.
Temporary, making it passable.
Throw up to six.
Enter stealth mode and make yourself hidden.
Maybe.
Oh, to enemies that were...
far away maybe it doesn't work on close range i think yeah
1k damage no 10 damage yeah it's 100 damage why would it not
be a hundred why would they make it a thousand damage in
training mode just make it a hundred because we're in
training mode we're trying to see how much the damage is
like i don't understand prank me.
Oh, that was the most funniest prank ever, guys.
All right, we'll try it.
We'll try it, Uma.
I actually don't know what... I don't... I'm gonna get...
I'm gonna try getting a shotgun and the R9.
I think... I think the... Where was it?
I had the Vanguard.
The Vanguard was fine, I think.
But I think I was getting kills with the Vanguard, but,
uh... Yeah, I was like, why the fuck... It made me feel like
I was invincible.
Baby, I was like, get pranked, nerd.
I thought I was goddamn invincible, but apparently I was
not.
I couldn't, yeah, I want the bear.
I was definitely not invincible.
I thought I was gonna be a god.
I thought I was gonna hulk out.
I don't like that.
It's very pre-made.
That's one of my other critiques.
i can see it being fun but i definitely need friends to play
this game with to be really fun like but then like that's
not like you know a lot of people like playing these types
of games solo too so it's like i'm trying to give you i
guess i'm trying to give you guys a more like solo queue
experience um not in club players i just cute i don't keep
oh my god bro what do you You made not enough players!
This game just came out!
Yeah, I'm giving you guys the true solo queue experience.
Like, maybe if you know this game more, the solo queue
experience would be better, but I'm still learning this.
Yeah.
I don't, like, I think it's just...
I definitely pre-mades just seem more insane.
Yeah, people are stuck in queue.
What do you mean?
Not enough.
Okay, I'm going to try shotgun and another LMG.
Alright, let's get it in.
Thank you, Patrice.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Also, they did pick Monday as the release date.
That's such a weird day to pick.
Jordan's school day, too.
No!
I'm fucking trying Scarlet, I guess.
I mean, Scarlet or...
yeah i'm gonna do it i'm gonna dps i wanted to play umma i
don't know guys pick whatever i don't think it matters where
the like i guess it does because like oh my god look to see
rainbow six siege the breach stuff yeah we hate monday what
does pre-made means it means like you already have a set
squad so it's not like a solo queue experience where you
just go in and like have like players who are solo queue
especially since this is not rank it's quick play so the the
the of skill rise of players in a quick play match is all
over the place so that's also another thing to be aware of
because you're like everybody is like different skill level
all right i tried to that vanguard right what's the dynasty
like you must have excellent smithson you learned yeah leads
balance beauty precision and strength if he leaves three
quick plays wait oh i didn't know that you've got some
pretty good knife i think like that's another honest you
made art and life reinforced everything i just throw mine
hope i hit someone not the streamers though a lot of
streamers are going in with pre-made and they're terrorizing
the lobbies from what i've heard a lot of the streamers that
got invited to the high guard event are come going in with
pre-made because they knew they fucking knew they're like
because Because they had the early access.
10 seconds to go.
So they're terrorizing the lobbies right now.
Because there's no SPMM because everybody is literally
learning the game.
The shield breaker is forming soon.
Alright.
Gather anything you need.
They fucking knew.
They knew this would be more fun with premades.
Oh, what the fuck?
I'm so bad at this.
Oh,
where are the loot's here?
And I believe they'll know where the fucking loot spawns
too, because I don't know where the fuck the loot spawns.
That's also another thing.
Like, where the fuck are the chests?
Where are the chests?
Bear time.
Alright.
There we go.
Yoink mine.
I don't know if we shared gems.
Where the fuck are the chests?
No, wait, actually.
Or is it just all gems?
Is this just a gem map?
There's no fucking...
God damn, I hate this mechanic.
I actually hate this mechanic.
Oh my god.
Okay, I think, like, obviously, when I get better at it, it
would be a lot easier for me.
But right now, I'm like, God, God, God, damn it.
Like, obviously, it would become muscle memory when I'd
fucking do it more.
But, like, right now, when I'm learning it, it's, like,
frustrating when I miss the thing.
Because I'm not used to doing these.
the more you play it'll become become muscle memory but
right now i'm not used to it right now so i i'm not a fan
but obviously obviously if i'm like
bumper charge grab more armor
helmet here i'm going to the shield breaker wait did i just
saw someone there i did Go see what else the wall has been
helping me out though I will say Oh saw an enemy
Oh I hear him What the fuck Oh my god he's droning Oh my god
they're actually droning right now
22 bullets in a dream
all right shield break is ready grab it
holy shit let the sands cloak me all right
scanning for enemies scanning we have enemies nearby get
ready mark some movement
you should just go for it yeah
why did it destroy okay all right we should be able to grab
someone grab the sword i don't want to grab it oh my god oh
my god he fucking okay fuck it let's go i didn't want to
grab it anyway i'm at the i'm gonna go protect my buddy all
right no this this team is easier to fight against for sure
i'm on the move i'm very slow climbing i'm gonna flank here
there's no like sheaving weapons though which I've noticed I
don't know where the other guy is yeah seconds
before overtime all right oh shit all right don't worry I
got you I got you don't
worry Okay, it's fine.
I got you.
All right.
Final time, team.
Who asked the story?
Breach, breach, breach!
Breach!
They shot the bear!
Everyone get ready to raid.
Seach tower rolling in.
All right, breach, breach!
Calling Wakanda!
Charla is here.
All right.
We're breaching.
Yeah, no, I wish this was 3v3v3.
I think it's like more like Bedwars, you know?
It'll be more chaotic, like choosing the team you want to...
I guess it's like, it's like more unfair, I guess, people
will feel that.
March the movement.
Watch this.
Oh my god.
Never mind.
What the fuck.
Are you fucking kidding me?
All right, there you go.
Oh, shit.
There we go.
I have my knives.
No!
I want...
Okay, I don't like...
Okay, this is much more...
I don't play jet.
guys.
I wanted to see if I could kill them with it.
I definitely don't play shit.
I've never played Valorant.
Do it.
I'm gonna grab.
I feel like my thing is like super definitely feels super
fucking.
Okay.
Where is he?
I'm breaching.
What the?
There you go.
Holy shit.
Alright.
We purged it?
Nice.
Okay, I fucking, I was still low.
I- Yeah!
Nade!
Okay, that was a sick-ass Nade.
Nice.
That Nade was sick, though.
I'm gonna use my shotgun.
Swapping weapons is hard, though.
Okay.
Hello?
I need to like figure out my sense.
I feel like it's all over the place in general.
I have no idea what my sense is.
All right.
Bum for charge.
Bum planted.
This is it.
Defend it and we're out.
All right.
Oh my god, I'm reloading.
Oh my god.
There you go Where oh he's through that enemies are near our
jack-o-de-seed That's not good Oh my god, he smoked.
Oh my god.
We lost our tower be careful out there
Yeah Fantastic job team see it's funny when your team knows
what the fuck they're doing he couldn't stop running okay
that one was fun i think the time to kill is fast though the
time to kill is definitely it's fun when you win it's fun
but i'm still like it's still i'm still figuring things out
i'm definitely i'm still trying to figure shit out it's like
very complicated yeah that's what i'm saying it it seems
really fun in the pre-made especially if you're calming and
everything if you're calming your tactics and everything
also i knew it i knew umma is like fucking op this guy is so
op you can like plant like you're literally planting turrets
like you're planting turrets and you have like a giant like
iron golem blocking the main entrance Like, that shit seems
broken.
Yeah, what's her name?
Una?
Una.
I need to figure out my sense.
I don't know if it's, like, too high or too low.
I don't like there's no, like, uh, right.
I can't tell if it's too high or too low right now.
I'll keep it for, maybe I'll lower it for now.
Is it overwhelmingly negative?
Because, like, I think like three I think it's because like
it's not a solo queue experience I can tell why it's
negative just because it's not a solo queue experience it's
only for like because like if you look at other apex you can
solo queue it because there's like a lot of movement tech
you can do because it's like if it's like siege if it's like
siege then it's more fun when you're like in a team or if
you're stacking it and stuff oh it's kicking people out and
time to get into
yeah people are still queuing so it's expected
but like i wouldn't say it's like bad i wouldn't say this is
a bad game i think if it's maybe if it's like 3v3v3 maybe
it'd be better but like
3v3 seems too compact for such a big ass map it felt like i
was Like, in the trailer, it felt like I was going to play
with, like, more people.
The footsteps are...
It's very esporty.
I will say this can have an esport game.
It can get, like, intense esport-wise.
Because Rainbow Six Siege.
Even though, like, the casuals don't play.
It's not a casual game, I think.
This is not casual-coded.
I think that's the main biggest problem.
This game is not casual-coded for people.
I am a keeper of trees.
I think.
Yeah.
It doesn't feel casual for casuals.
It feels like it's more so like for the hardcore gamers.
Like the competitive gamers.
The rank for this might thrive.
I think.
I think rank wise this game can thrive and it's more like
more for more competitive stuff but not for the casuals.
No I just tabbed out that's why I was tabbing out.
and then i can tell this will get really frustrating like
siege with like the court like the stuff that the corners
you do and stuff like that oh he doesn't know he doesn't
know the oldest dog
i think the quick play because like i think i think what oh
my god this guy already knows the meta i think like there's
gonna be a lot of like thinking going on regarding like uh
oh this be fucking frustrating.
I am out.
Like, where the fuck do I reinforce in general?
I don't know if I like I don't know, Dynasty or... I'm gonna
try the Viper now.
I'm gonna try... I guess Viper Vanguard?
Because I can use Viper for close range.
I feel like the moment people figure out the meta, this is
gonna be a very frustrating game for people.
Like, for, like, non-casuals.
Because, like, Rainbow Six Siege has a really bad entry
point into the game.
Because, like, because it's just so hard to...
It's not welcoming to new players in general, I feel, for
Rainbow Six Siege.
And I think this game could be similar in the future.
When people, like, figure out the meta and stuff.
because I don't know if I can see casual players playing
this for long term because like with the stuff you have to
learn too I think I think with this yeah all the stuff you
have to learn for this game and like the corners like the
corners and gunplay and everything is going to be very
frustrating I can tell yeah I think it's a it's definitely a
sweaty game want to try.
I fucking hate I don't have the muscle memory yet.
Alright.
I would definitely want to try this game out as a pre-made.
For sure.
Oh my god.
I'm God of warring.
I wonder if this is like good loot in here.
I think.
Yeah?
Yeah I knew it.
Okay.
Yeah like shit like this.
You know?
Uh...
like shit like this like oh i have to make sure i i i go
here for like extra loot and stuff like that and then we
have to start camping near the shield breaker to grab for
and i have to mine this so if i need more armor if i'm
getting breached i can i can have loot ready in time
like every i will say everyone is learning the game right
now so yeah i have to have this so if i die at least i would
have emergency armor god fucking so bad at this
oh was that a person brought me something useful i see oh
hey nice
someone over there but i might be delusional maybe he'll
are you fucking kidding me oh my god bro
that guy did not know
okay these guys can aim these guys can aim that's bad
oh my god these guys are aimers though i swear to god this
is a pre-made i I swear to fucking God.
I swear to fucking God if this is a pre-made.
This better be just someone really good at aiming.
Okay, they're going this way.
I'm gonna head over to our buddy here.
Our guy's gonna like get fucking ganked on soon.
Yeah, I fucking do it.
shot at right now.
Lead up for that.
Not bad.
Yeah, see, this is the thing I don't like here.
It's just literally we're just trying to camp each other.
Yeah, I don't know if I'm a fan of that in general.
It's just like literally we're just camping the storm
breaker out type deal.
It seems very frustrating.
Time to pick up.
Move in.
This is our shot.
Alright.
We're getting into the overtime stretch.
Yeah, that's how you're supposed to play it, but it's
like...
That's why I'm like, personally, I'm not a huge fan of
Rainmaker mode.
I actually really hate Rainmaker mode in Splatoon.
Mounting up.
Let's move.
The movement is...
Alright.
Rise and fight, we sprout.
Oh, maybe not this...
Definitely not this gun.
I'll try... I'm still figuring out the...
Yeah, not this gun.
I got... I think... What was the other one?
Jesus Christ!
I gotta wait.
I had a regen.
Remaker is just frustrating.
I want to know what the meta guns are.
There you go.
There
you go.
Oh, I want to know what the gun meta is though.
Grab this just in case.
Breaching, breaching, breaching!
Breaching!
I see you!
I see...
I'm broke.
Oh, they don't know!
They don't know!
Oh, they don't know you can't see this.
Okay, same here.
I was just like you, and I didn't know.
I didn't know you can't shoot anything.
Don't worry, I was just like you.
But I couldn't...
I didn't realize I couldn't shoot through the shield.
I'm just like you.
Don't worry.
I was just like you
Fuck that I'm wasted I know I wasted that but like I
couldn't be bothered I really didn't want to fucking deal
with these people Oh my god that's so strong Holy shit wait
that is so strong
Oh my god we are not as insane
Oh my god wait Arnon
Holy fuck!
Okay, I hope somebody is breaching this.
Guys, I swear to God, I did so much already.
But then...
No, no!
That's unlucky.
Oh my god, no.
That shit was crazy.
Holy fuck.
Okay, this was the main bomb.
Okay, that's what I needed to know.
I was like, which was the main bomb?
I was like, oh my god, I got to buy.
I forgot to buy.
Okay, I know I like...
Okay, I know like which gun is like super...
My team's fucking dog shit, by the way.
My team is...
Oh my god, I literally got rushed at.
Really?
Oh my god, I got fucking...
ran at there i felt like i did so much during that fight i
literally won v3 i i literally won v3 i lose base health if
we fail the raid oh my god i don't know if i like that i
guess to make it more fair but still i don't know i don't
know it's fucking bullshit that I lose I lose fucking things
if I yeah it punishes you yeah no this gun is OP if I can
upgrade this gun my what is it called my viper this shit is
okay that is literally the R9 yeah like yeah I guess I get
punished for it but still about dog shit teammate got
breached properly this
is a apparently a good one
that's fine there you go there's a good ass loot what the
fuck last timer I'll fucking grab that amulet revive we'll
grab that just in case all right Thank you.
Oh, nice.
Grab it if you need it.
Alright, let's see what the airdrop is.
Oh my god, okay, I was gonna sit.
Alright, that's OP.
Like, like, she can grab, get loot and shit right off the
bat.
That shit's broken, I feel.
Anybody here at the airdrop?
They're literally all there.
Why is my team not the airdrop?
I hate my team.
I hate my team
They're they're tired.
They're all there already and then my team was like la-deed
up
Like a fucking course I already hate my team.
I think I hate them a lot only because I literally 1v3'd and
like I was like where are they?
Which is fine Where's my team?
Oh my god Like where are they like bro?
What the fucking?
Oh my god, this sucks
This where did they go?
What
I told you yet this is not a solo queue experience like what
the fuck was he doing there Stopping off to buy some like
honestly Bro, what are you doing?
It's go time group.
The enemy picks up the shield breaker.
Intercept them.
Like they're already all convened there and then my team was
like, it's a miracle that we live this far.
There they are.
Enemy is approaching our base.
They've got the shield breaker.
Now I'm off the bear though.
Reloading.
Mounting up, let's move.
I don't...
They're on the other side.
We have to go this side.
They're gonna breach it.
It doesn't matter.
Yeah, they're gonna breach it.
How did my team die?
What?
Two people are he...
Oh my god.
Oh no.
No, this is not a solo queue.
Not a solo queue experience.
Oh my god.
Oh my.
Yeah, no, I fucking know you are.
I'm not solo cute.
Not solo cute.
Not it.
Solo cute ain't it.
My team is actually goddamn stupid.
It killed my fucking mother of trees.
Why are you standing there?
Oh my god.
You're fucking welcome!
Hostile here!
Are you fucking...
Whisp, stand watch here.
Here we go.
Oh...
I have to get out of that.
Oh my god, this sucks!
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh, I had to reload!
I had to reload!
kill me risk oh my god I had to reload oh my god I don't I
hate my team I really do I I really do not like my team bro
I wish I could I'm literally one man arming this
oh my god are you not shooting with me okay what is your aim
what is your aim I there's no way there's no way like he was
not dead I hit him so many are you oh my God give me your
POV give me your aim POV right now I need it I want to see
your aim right now I that guy should have been dead I did a
hundred and twenty something damage oh my god i was like i'm
not i'm not feeling it i thought that was my teammate i
legitimately thought i was my teammate i'm crashing out i
need i'm crashing out right now i am this is actually so
tilting i'm actually so tilted to play with playing with
these people
there you go scene at right now
I hear him.
Like the ammo is so low though, that's the only issue.
The ammo is so low for this.
Like yeah, you're welcome.
This gun does so much DPS, but you have, I have to have it
upgraded because like the mag is so goddamn shit.
The mag is actually so bad.
I didn't reload the other gun.
This goddamn stupid fucking movement.
Get out of here.
Get out of here
I have to reload.
It's 26 but it's so fast.
I need it like an actual other Oh my god Yeah, no my I my
team My team is not it.
I'm actually so mad like I this is why I don't play siege
Stopping off to buy some tea.
Oh my god, yes.
Oh my god, I replaced the wrong gun.
Oh, whatever.
Whatever.
I replaced the wrong gun.
Whoops, I have double vipers now.
Oops, double vipers.
Oh, thank god.
Okay, I was gonna say it.
I'll be so sad if I...
Alright.
That's gonna be like, oops, double vipers.
Where the hell do we go?
Alright.
Oh my god, everybody.
I can't even sell, you know, you can't
I gotta make sure I reload, too Like, I think, like
No, it's just my team I wonder if there's aim assist on this
I swear to God Alright, guys, where's my team?
Oh, they're still back at base?
Oh, okay, I guess we Okay, okay what the oh my god my team
is still at base my team is still at base
guys they're not even attempting that fight for the sword
that's crazy that's actually crazy they're not even gonna
try to go for the sword okay guys
bro i'm also new i'm oh my god thank god okay this guy at
least is here what do we i'm awesome we're all due shield
breakers forming if the enemy gets it they win
so we have to get it if they get it it's literally ggs
but god that guy going in straight up off the bat that's
crazy this guy's crazy
Oh my god, I can naturally fall from here.
Brought me something you saw, I see.
Alright, skills here.
Okay, that's their best player, I'm pretty sure.
There you go.
Oh!
I grabbed the goddamn shield breaker!
Oh my god.
grab the goddamn shield breaker i'm right behind go go i'm
right behind don't look back get on your goddamn panther bro
get the fuck out of your panther why are you looking back at
me
oh my god i feel like i'm babysitting right now i i oh my
god i'm babysitting right now okay this guy is so scared
he's actually so fucking nervous right now
why did you one item you fucking stupid oh my god where's my
oh my god where is he
that the viper is so strong though the viper really is so
goddamn strong why are you shotgunning from 20 miles i can't
i i should never i
what oh my god wait i can literally spawn with my teammates
too wait that's crazy oh no this is bad for me i'm dead here
there's no way so one reason he's the support is strong you
know what he does i realized something about i realized
something about the support um They like, they like, they
just give themselves over heal and then go straight in.
Like, that's what I realized.
They literally give themselves over heal and then just go
in.
That's so smart, actually.
That's actually incredibly smart.
Guys, we have to.
Yeah, they do self-shield.
I think the support is actually one of the strongest, I
think, because of that.
Summoning a whisk.
up on our base we'll stop them or they'll win please stop
them please don't let me be the only one to stop them yeah
see the overheels fucking crazy don't
make me be the only one that shoots them guys and fight we
sprout
guys oh my god oh my god okay we lost
oh my i wish i have enough it's okay there's so many people
playing I will never see them again.
I will never see them again.
It's okay.
That's fine.
I'm fine with that.
Oh my god.
My connection for Haggad has lost.
Yo, can I get a team with nothing?
Oh my god.
back to waiting in queue waiting in my login queue let me
see let me see if i can let me see if i can crap let me mess
let's see who's like solo queue right now who's going
through solo queue hell like me uh all right i tabbed out
i'm checking to see if anyone is anyone is fucking going
through you hell right now i'm oh my god oh my god
i'm just i just oh man i my god i'm just i hate my teammates
so much i hate my teammates and so
it's it's not solo q coded it feels like it's especially
like you know in other games you can possibly 1b3 if you
have the aim but like the time to kill is like relatively
fast to the point where it's like pretty difficult to like i
did 1b3 but because i also had a box though I had a box to
play around.
But when you're in the open, you tend to not have a fucking
box.
Oh my god.
Alright.
Ha.
I feel like Mimi...
Okay, I'm gonna try her.
The guy that played her was crazy.
Was crazy.
The overshield is insane.
like for extra HP.
So I feel like she might be really...
She might be actually the one for solo Q.
No, yeah, no.
Like, dealing with my randoms was just...
The overshield definitely looks very strong.
We're going to try that.
I'm going to check if there's a sense converter now.
Sense converter.
Hi, guard.
um have they made a high guard sense converter yet hi oh
they did thank the lord okay they actually did i've been
like i don't know how to 1.89 0.472 okay that's good to know
all right i found my sense they already made it 0.472 at
least it's free to play at least oh my god someone already
dc'd At least, guys, guys, it is free to play.
Oh, my gosh, I swear, don't you not kick me out.
I swear to God, I was in the login queue.
Do not kick me.
Guys, with my reaction, do you really think it's sponsored?
Do you...
I'm giving you the raw experience right now.
All right.
Let me...
Okay, I found out my sense here.
0.47
I wish I could just I wish I could type it You know You know
those moments?
Oh my God I'm at Okay that actually makes more sense
actually I didn't realize I was at 140 We're gonna put on
medium because now I've already Seen how what it's like
Alright Now at 240 maybe it'll be Better for me Subtitles
Okay maybe I'll be like, when able your character, I fucking
auto-run.
Let's go.
Oh, man, auto-running.
I auto-run in Apex anyway.
Alright.
Alright, here you go.
The thing is, a lot of people don't, don't, can't fucking
have a pre-made go-in, too.
It's like, i wish it was more casual friendly for the
players who don't have like i won't say don't have friends
but you know might not have a might not have a good three
stack to go in you know i swear how how this one Yeah.
What?
Who said that?
Who the fuck said that?
Oh my god.
You know, scheduling issues.
Boo.
Oh.
No.
Match found.
I swear to God.
Can I get a game?
Can I...
It's because, like, if someone...
I guess they don't have a...
They don't have a re-queue system type deal.
Like, if someone drops out, they don't have, like, someone
filling in instantly.
Okay.
Calm down.
You might have good teammates.
okay you know four times the charm guys for four times the
charm it's okay it's okay where did jeff get his confidence
i just wanted
where did he get where did he get did he have two friends to
play this with Must be nice.
It must be fucking nice bro.
Okay, when I saw like streamers being like I've been
thinking about this game since I Since I went to this event.
I was like must be nice to be playing in the pre-made must
be fucking nice Must be so fucking nice to have people
coming and playing in a pre-made.
Oh No fucking wonder you had a great time I have friends too
just you know they're playing a Oh my god, please, I just
need one more player
Oh my god, where are my players?
Oh, I just wanna play a game
I just I just wanted to know what it was like myself Oh my
god, it punishes you for not having friends.
That's so fucked up Some people just don't have friends that
play every game.
It's not my fault.
How?
Why does it punish me for not having friends?
Why?
What if I want to make friends in this game?
Are these friends of yours in the room with us right now?
Let's see.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, my.
Oh my god!
It's okay.
We could do this.
Oh my god!
Why would you put me in a match?
I've only played three games!
Why are they only playing three games?
Okay, it's been two hours and I've only played three games.
If this is what you get for hope, but you rest it, thank you
for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Maybe six times the charm.
Guys, I don't think they're gonna sponsor me ever.
I don't think they're watching.
I'm sorry.
But please, I just won another game.
Guys, that's...
No.
Oh!
Please!
Oh no!
one day I will know what it's like to play with people one
day I'll get into a game one one maybe I waited a little bit
I waited I waited a little bit maybe it'll be different
maybe this is what purgatory looks like kill thank you for
The super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Maybe it's because the same five people are queuing up at
the same time.
I've waited a little bit now.
So maybe this time, this time, that will get a six out of
six.
This time.
I know why not just wait for, I'm pretty sure there's so
many people queuing up.
Oh my god.
That's like a go!
It was literally the same five people queuing up over and
over.
again.
We did it.
We fucking did it.
We actually we made it.
We made it in.
We fucking did it.
Oh.
It was truly the hardest.
This has to be the hardest game of my life because I
couldn't get in a fucking game.
I broke the cycle.
I fucking broke the cycle.
We did it.
We pulled through.
Holy shit, a fourth game.
All right.
We got our fourth game.
All right, Viper.
I don't know if I like Vanguard or Dynasty more.
Which one did you guys think was felt better?
I couldn't tell, honestly.
I personally couldn't tell what was better.
No, the matches feel too long.
Especially if you're losing.
I wanted to just, like, surrender.
Fantasy is better.
Alright, we'll try.
Yeah, I couldn't tell, like, for me, honestly.
I don't know.
Fuck it.
Oh, I don't know.
You guys can reinforce.
Can somebody reinforce this right here?
Oh, my God.
People are calming.
Can I...
Can you actually reinforce?
where's that oh my god people are actually calming let's go
let's go oh my god we have comers we have tryhard all right
i'm gonna fucking i still i need to figure out where the
goddamn loot is in this goddamn game
Oh, nice.
I'll grab that.
I feel like when you figure out... Oh my god, the loot path
too.
Yeah, I figure out the fucking loot path for each map Which
is gonna be like really frustrating
For sure Yeah, figure out the loot path for this and like
I'm I don't know the loot path right now I'm gonna head over
right now to them
I don't know the fucking loot path Oh, I don't See, I have I
have Dynasty and Viper Don't worry
These guys know where things are I don't fucking know where
things are right now Yeah Like where the fuck are items
anywhere In this Yeah Yeah Yeah Where are anything?
I don't know.
It's fine.
Is there actually...
Did I actually took fall damage?
I'm hearing some shit, to be honest.
To the left.
I'll give this to him.
Oh my god.
Wait, there's...
I thought...
I guess there's no fall damage when you're on your goddamn
fucking horse.
Okay, yeah, there's a player.
over here you don't take fall damage when you're on your
horse i found out apparently stupid goddamn
horse shield breakers forming at the water pumps move
they're there they're there they're there they're there yeah
i
got one i got one i got one One over here.
Out of the other.
Got another one.
Alright.
How do I fucking grab it?
Hurry up.
Alright, there we go.
Who wants to grab it?
Because I don't.
Kraken.
all right oh there's like a there's a cool down apparently
there's a cool down to your over shield okay i found that
there's a cool down do it which makes sense actually
oh here
me picked up the shield breaker intercept them oh foe
eliminated that's up oh my god oh i only this way i wasn't
gonna get him yeah i can't observe him because like i had to
deal with there was a guy to my left i had to deal with
which sucks that sucks i had to deal with a guy to my left
so i couldn't help my team I wanted to help him, but a
stupid guy was behind and was here left purchasing gear from
the charlatan.
Yeah, I need this.
See over there?
There are me there I mean shield shield shield breakers on
it All right mounting up grenade out Spotted the shield
breakers close to our Oh, this is bad.
Oh.
Reloading.
One of them's low.
One of them should be really low.
Listen up, Gru.
No more spawns.
We're in extra time.
I'm trying to help this guy.
Wait, the shield breaker's behind me.
Just two enemies left.
Oh my god, they got the...
bro i couldn't get there in time bro oh my god they got the
raid that's unlucky that's fucking unlucky all right i'll
just defend it oh heads up they're coming in ready weapons
armor let's make them regret it i'll give him
Focus fire!
There we go.
Holy shit, I have to be so focused during the stupid break
shit.
Alright.
Here?
He's so low.
There we go.
Oh my god, I gotta be so fucking- If we defend this, we will
do damage.
on the side
there you go give me that soul no no give me that soul no
i'm stupid
i need that soul
yeah low low low low
that's fine oh that guy is like
nice low on you to your left most What the fuck?
Sacrifice!
Nice.
Alright.
Pacom!
Successful!
Alright, let's see.
Purple.
Dynasty.
Alright.
Oh, I still need to figure out the loot path.
Oh, this is good movement.
I don't know if you guys saw that.
But if you do this and then They're so fast.
Look how fast that is.
That's actually crazy movement right there.
I'm figuring out tech, guys.
Yeah, the slide with the bear.
That shit is fast.
I can see people using that, actually.
It's an incoming airdrop.
How are you supposed to fucking know where that shit's at?
It's right here.
It's literally...
It's like on the...
How are you supposed to know where it is?
It's literally in on the map.
I told you guys, this game is more fun.
We have a team that comms and like, it's like either a team
that knows what the fuck they're doing.
And comms and shit.
You guys wanna go for the airdrop?
Airdrop is like, here.
Let's travel here.
Oh, they're still learning, yeah, they are.
It was just frustrating when you get a team as a solo queuer
that fucking is confused 24-7.
These people actually know what they're doing and shit.
My darkspawn energy surges.
All right.
I thought there was like another area here.
What's in the loop?
Oh yeah, the airdrops right there.
Is above us?
Oh, it's above us.
How the fuck do you get up here?
What the?
Okay, whatever.
Fuck this.
I guess I'll go.
Y'all can get that drop.
I don't even know how to get up there.
I don't even know how to show break here.
I don't even know how to fucking get up there.
I'm like behind them.
stuff oh this game good it's up it's more for like if you
have a team type fun for sure oh foe spotted it's not like a
i'm gonna put
i'm gonna fucking summon the shit got some treasure for you
grenade out oh shit they're all here they're all here
they're all here yeah no Fucking shit.
Ping them.
Oh my god.
I literally can't see shit.
There you go.
Oh.
Take this so long.
Alright.
Nice.
my sacrifice get over here move with me so i don't die all
right oh they're they're they're approaching right side on
the hill right here okay
nice good shots dude
it will all be over soon okay armor here protect yourself
protect yourself protect yourself Yeah, let's go!
Wait, maybe I just play with these guys.
Oh, he doesn't know!
He doesn't know!
It's so stupid.
You're so fucking stupid.
Bro, I'm gonna...
Who is the guy that talks?
Who's the guy that's talking, guys?
Alright, lock it, boys.
I'm gonna go B.
I'm gonna pop my...
Oh my god, he's gonna go B.
We're breaching?
Rush B?
We're rushing!
Get in there!
Get over here, soldier!
Rush me!
Sacrifice!
Descend into darkness!
Rush me!
Ready to call upon you.
That's fine.
So long, my time!
Just rush me!
It's always worked!
Okay, no, this girl is strong as hell
Sol!
Alright.
Fuck ya.
Yeah!
Where's the other one?
Oh, it's over here.
That's fucking hard, give me!
Oh my god.
Come back to the living!
Oh, shit.
I touched your soul.
Oh, my God.
Okay, I'm fucked up right now.
What the fuck?
Oh, shit.
It's good.
We won again.
Easy as shit, what?
We secured this location.
We did it.
I touched your soul.
Please respond.
Yeah, I know I fucking carry the shit out of them.
Who was it?
Who was the one that talked?
I want to be on this guy's team.
I want all that.
I have for a five minute game.
Okay.
Yeah, having a team that comes is pretty nice.
Divino.
All right, he's coming with me.
He's like, you're coming with me.
I knew what he was doing.
He calmed.
I like that.
Deep.
It's fun.
It's fun when I have someone that talks.
It's just sometimes you don't get those people.
It's this guy, right?
Bro, I send you a friend request.
Please respond.
Come on.
Get in here.
I sent you a hug.
I had friend request please please respond for everyone
who's fucking playing this like
no i just i wasn't wait is sure for it is sure for in the
party let me check let me check real quick why is he in the
set oh he's in the setting oh he is god damn it he's in the
pre-made i fucking knew it sure for it i i'm like Yeah, he's
in the pre-made.
He is.
I told you.
Goddamn pre-made buff right there.
Goddamn pre-made buff.
It's always a pre-made buff.
What a nerd having friends.
Having free.
Bro, I would tell Gully to kick Sturport and then invite me.
And I knew it.
I know I'm the only one.
I told you guys.
All the streamers that, like, had, like, the They got the
invite new They fucking knew They knew like It's just better
in the pre-made I didn't know I was playing solo I didn't
know I came in here With zero knowledge
I came here I didn't know Yeah pre-made is those who already
came in there with two friends going in because they knew it
was much much better experience
i did it was very too late i got warned the day i did still
they i did but the thing is i got told a date right
literally like the yesterday so there was no time to make a
pre-made reinforce the base and armor there was no time to
make pre-mades it was Run it, re-rip it.
We do it live.
Like, I don't know what to reinforce.
Like, what the fuck do you...
Oh, I reinforced the wrong thing.
This has no bomb.
Whoops.
If you like siege, I guess.
I guess if you like siege, you'll like this game.
Because it's very siege-y.
The gunplay is less...
The gunplay is, like, apex type deal, sort of.
But, like, it's still, like...
That's it.
Reinforcing a wall.
The time to kill is also quite low.
Yeah.
Dome's opening in 10.
Ready up team.
I think I found my load up though.
I like this load up.
I like my current load up.
And then I have to know the loot paths, but I don't know the
loot paths too.
Like if you know the, like you have to play like.
It's like people be like, I want to play Dust 2 only because
that's the good best best loot path for some shit Because
like I haven't played this map before where the fuck is the
loot?
Where is the loot?
I'll make my own loot.
Fuck this I don't care Yeah
grab it I need armor though really bad okay all right it
really is and it's like it's like quick play too so like you
get people from different types different um skill level so
you can't guarantee that your team will be okay like you
know you know because like you know literally I played four
matches And, like, my teams have been all over the place.
I haven't had a close game yet.
I've yet to have a close game.
It's literally, like, if your teammates are, like, not
fucking stupid.
Like...
Yeah, no guarantees there.
It's more...
It's, like, literally, teammate RNG.
Is your teammate special or not?
The ammo is so low.
I will say ammo is so fucking low.
For this type deal.
Oh, people are here.
People are on me.
People are already on me.
We have to go.
Foes spotted.
There's very people here.
Oh my god.
There we go.
Reloading.
You've got baddies nearby.
Like that.
See, you know what I mean?
Is there like, oh, is my teammate good enough?
Like, look, like, literally, I literally carry that.
I literally carry that myself, single-handedly.
Oh my god, did he fell?
Did he fucking fall grab it grab it you grab grab the sword.
I can aim Oh my I hate my team.
I hate my grab grab the sword.
I am literally your aimer Yes, grab oh my god.
I'm so I'm literally the person that aims for you
I'm just okay I'm literally the teammate that can aim for
us.
So it's like, are you fucking kidding me?
Yeah.
Summoning a siege tower.
Jumping a siege tower.
Get ready.
Siege tower coming in.
Oh my god.
You guys are so lucky.
lucky I'm here.
You guys, oh my god.
Take my soul.
You guys are so lucky.
I'm your teammate.
You, you guys, oh my god.
I, holy shit.
I'm literally one-vading this fucking army right now.
Okay, I can't.
I can go anywhere right now.
I literally don't trust my teammates.
We've got baddies now.
Okay.
Someone's shooting me!
Your foe eliminated!
So long here, protect yourself.
Yours wide open.
Harvesting enemy soul.
Oh my god.
Making up some baddies.
Getting hit.
Your own will take the win.
Defensive.
There you go.
Let the souls of the whole and fortify you.
Harvesting enemies.
Wait, I can harvest.
Wait, that's crazy.
No!
Oh my god, we got it.
We got it.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
We got the bomb off.
I'm here.
That's okay.
Oh, it's okay.
It's okay.
We have...
All right.
That's okay.
diffused guys I need you guys to actually okay it's okay
it's okay
I'm gonna help our my TV here nice
nice that's fine I didn't buy armor you should be able to
kill him There you go.
It's fine.
We're... It's okay.
I have...
It's fine.
I had to... It's a 2v1.
It was a 2v1.
It's understandable.
Like, it's okay.
We did make a lot of progress.
We made a lot of progress here.
Oh, wait.
I already have.
God damn it.
Alright, we go.
Alright, goodbye.
Goodbye.
I leave now.
I need...
Armory team keep it going for the next one nice spawn back.
Oh, I can okay You can jump back to base whenever All right,
that's good.
Okay now I learned that you can jump whatever the next
shield breaker team All right, let me let me grab this
Dynasty I'll replace that All right All right, that's fine
Okay but this this character is very OP like straight off
the bat it's like what's her name it's literally like the is
it Viper from Valorant literally how it feels I can't get
off mine if I fall like that
yeah like where I could oh Reina that's her name yeah it
feels like Reina yeah that's how she feels with the shield
and stuff
that's how I feel when I play her yeah so our Viper was the
what was it was the poison girl but she feels like she feels
like Raina with the overshield the overshield is crazy like
I'm having fun in gun fights I will say like gun fights are
fun like it's very Very skill for gunfights.
But it's still...
It's so...
How did I say it?
It's just so heavy dependent on your team.
I mean, like, I'm literally, like, their carry right now,
honestly.
What the fuck is my airdrop?
There you go.
Like, I feel like I'm single-handedly carrying this team.
Airdrop shattered.
Armor here.
Protect yourself.
big rig i'll try that all right i'll try that i don't know
if this is good um all right let's see this gun
5v5 i don't think the map is big enough for 5v5 honestly i
feel like it's gonna be way too chaotic for it i wonder
they'll follow me or not how do i oh they're trying to
follow me i don't What the fuck?
Okay.
She's not in this way.
They're like, she must know where she's going.
Sorry, buddy.
I'm just as confused as you.
Oh, wait.
It stayed.
I threw this a lot.
I was going to sit.
I'm pretty sure I got that a while ago.
I don't know.
The shield break is ready for me.
And we're not there.
Shield break is ready.
We're not even there.
This is bad.
This is a bad gun.
This is not close range.
Which is really bad for us.
What?
Oh, I didn't see him.
Nah, that gun sucked.
That was my bad.
I didn't know what that gun...
I didn't know if it was long range or not.
Well, now I do.
are you serious oh my god we let him run we let him run into
the siege god damn it i'm so sad we let him run over oh my
god he just ran past us like what i did
i had no idea what that did though to be fair
Where?
Grenade out!
Reloading!
We've got another dome breach.
Seal it!
Ah!
The fire!
So long, here.
Protect yourself.
It will all be overseen.
Alright.
Shifted this wall.
Slide through?
Where the fuck are they?
We've got baddies nearby.
I hear him.
Heads up.
They're planting a bomb.
Intercept.
There we go.
That's fine.
We defused it.
Alright.
I'm like so confused.
These guys are all so confused.
Like I...
I'm confused they're confused you can now walk through this
wall whenever you call in an extra eye I hear him where
though I'm so confused all right
oh wait how do I do this remove dome splitter What the fuck?
Let's clear him out.
What is that?
How do I remove this?
Okay, nice.
I was gonna say.
How the fuck do I remove that?
From all other side.
Oh!
Okay, got time before the next shield breaker team.
Oh, I see.
Okay, I get it.
That's it.
It's just, like, confusing.
Sometimes.
No, it's been upgraded.
I should.
Oh yeah, I should see my loot upgrade.
I should double check that.
Where's my little trading post?
There it is.
Uh, dynasty.
Get that helmet.
There you go.
Actually.
Bomb kit.
Give me my saddle.
Alright, there we go.
We gotta grab the airdrop too.
Okay, now I know big rig.
fucking sucks.
Oh, so it's like I can end their raid early type deal.
Is that it?
Guys, if you were not on your bear, you'd fucking die, by
the way.
For those who don't know, if you were not on the bear, you
actually fucking just die.
There is fall damage if you're not on the goddamn bear.
There's no mobs on your map.
Looking for movement.
I Mean it's a shooter game most of these guns it's just like
a template on what the guns are supposed to be
Oh these guys all right.
Yeah, he ain't getting that What else is in there?
Rocket launcher fuck it Yeah, no fuck the big rig That shit
was a scab.
That shit was...
Was a goddamn scab.
Let's get this shield breaker when it falls.
We planted.
It's done.
Oh my god, he's so lucky.
I'm reloading.
That guy is so lucky.
I want to protect my teammates from here.
We're going to head from here.
Summoning a dark spawn.
There's a third guy.
I knew it.
Fucking knew it.
Idiot.
Alright, let's go.
Let's go.
You have the shield breaker.
Just plant it and it's all over.
Alright, here we go.
Do they okay, I was gonna say okay grab the shield armor and
go Holy shit.
Okay, I'm gonna cover them.
I'm gonna cover them Like just go Like the gunplay is fine.
It is fine.
It's literally just
What the fuck what did I do there?
Let's take this home.
Drop the shield breaker.
Taking fire.
Oh, shit.
Mounting up.
Let the souls of the fallen fortify you.
Oh, my God.
Who has this?
She just needs to literally go the other way.
I have to go.
Oh, my God.
We had to...
I didn't even realize he had to.
had it oh my god i didn't even realize he lost the he had it
if i realized he had it i would have fucking bro he just
needed to run to the right side these guys oh my god oh my
god he literally just had to run he had to run to the other
side while we're fighting on left like use your brain Please
Please use your brain No more spawns or an extra time
Yeah, you see them Let the souls of I got the wrong gun Had
the wrong gun Shoot them please shoot them before they get
in oh my god
Oh, please
There we go.
Just two enemies left.
Oh my god.
He literally...
Are you fucking kidding me?
And then I got sniped.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
That's the smoke!
I'm gonna grab that.
That's actually like a smoke thing that's so funny oh that
is so frustrating we did not need to smoke this i feel that
defend and we can win i don't know where to go oh i don't
know this
oh there were two i didn't see two oh no i didn't realize
there were two i'm so stupid i saw one character on my
screen but it was actually two
Just throw the name!
Literally all...
I'm fucking...
Panicking right now.
Are you fucking kidding me?
I'm playing panic right now.
That sucks.
Oh!
I'm playing like... I'm playing like way too panicky.
I'm like too scared right now.
I respawned though.
I need to help my team.
There.
Alright.
Where is she?
Oh my god.
Someone shoot me.
Take this song off.
After reload.
Oh.
Death can wait.
I will not.
Yeah, there's so much stuff going on here.
It's on.
Their siege tower is done.
Now let's clear them out.
Heads up.
They're planting a bomb.
Intercept.
An enemy bomb is counting down.
We need to bind them.
My sky eyes looking for enemies.
The foe eliminated.
Let the darkness take you take this soul armor
We will meet again Oh my god Holy shit the lock in Oh my god
I like I like panicked there in the moment but that had to
lock in there Holy shit I was trying my best to like okay
focus focus I think what I don't like also is just the mag
is so small it's so small it's such a small mag oh okay
oh am I liking the game I think if I had a pre-made I would
like it more right now but I know this character this
character is so strong i think she she's the strong for me
personally she seems like the the strongest because she
plays like uh she plays like reina with the shields and
stuff yeah she the overhelp is insane yeah i think out of
all the characters her her and the recon is actually so
strong every time i have a recon character we win but she's
very she's the solo carry pick yeah yeah she's her and the
recon are insane in general um this is really good during
when you're reaching because it's like chaotic and stuff i
thought it was shit but like in the game is he's actually
really strong i think these three are like the strongest
character these three Execute from range, too.
I'll do...
Wait, how long I've been playing for?
And you're in three hours.
I'll do one more game.
I'm so sad.
I got never added me.
I sent you a friend with wishpilies responda.
You never responded.
No, you can't switch during game.
So you go in right off the bat.
Right off the bat.
I don't...
Um, I don't know if I want to play Slade, only because,
like, her overshield is just so strong, and I like...
I really like that, the playstyle of her.
Yeah.
She seems... I'll do one more.
But, in my opinion, that is the strongest character.
Yes, she has the solo carry potential.
I literally, like, 1v3 with the overshield.
Like, I literally get killed, overshield, run, and then...
and a little bit of HP and then go back in.
It's so fucking OP.
There we go.
I got her.
I got her!
Yeah, and it also denied revives, too.
Yeah.
Where's Lala gonna play?
Oh, alright.
I still am very confused with the with the breach stuff.
Yeah, I legit, yeah, I carried that whole game with Mara,
for sure, yeah.
It's, well, it's overwhelmingly negative because, like, it
was so hard to get into the game in general.
It's a, I only think it's, the reason why it's
overwhelmingly negative, too, is that it's multi, a lot of
multiplayer games are generally overwhelmingly negative.
Right, team.
Dome shields almost unlocked.
And also, because, like, it's complicated.
complicated it's very hard to figure out in general I'm like
every every game I'm learning more and more about what to do
but it is very frustrating to learn when you're still
especially because it's not like I said it's not casual
friendly I I can see myself liking this game if I'm playing
it in a more competitive environment but rank environment is
gonna be hell I can already tell especially I can tell
people are gonna be very toxic in rank especially if it's
3v3 and that everyone will just be premaking everyone's just
gonna do pre-mades it's like apex where like you can't
really rank up and you can't really rank up in apex solo
queue like it's just easier of a pre-made it's just around
that type of vibe but like but like it's not but like you
can still solo queue it's just it will be a hundred percent
more frustrating similar to how apex solo queue is it is
it's just it's like a game that it's like a game that has
basically all the stuff you've seen in other games but
combined into one fucking like pot
yeah but it's i it's not casual friendly 100 percent after
playing this like i don't know if casual players will like
it oh my god it's like god of war when i do that
it's a lot of different mechanics made into one type deal
yeah like i can see like what they're trying to do but it is
very overwhelming for a casual player like for me like you
know the moment i found a character i clicked with like
everything clicked for me you know like like how i'll take
that how like the moment it clicked i just like was just
killing everything with mara because i figured her out but
like the other characters you know i was just trying to be
like what the fuck do i do but for her like the moment i
figured it out it like it clicked instantly with like
movement gunplay and everything
it's just a lot it definitely is a lot and then obviously if
you have a team that comes with you that wants to play with
you you can do a lot of stuff with it it's very esporty type
deal it's like how the finals is not really casual friendly
it has a very it has a very like big esport market right now
like right now you guys didn't know you don't see the finals
Like, played a lot, like, a casual face.
Oh, my God.
That's bad.
They scanned me.
You know, I'm here.
I'm just gonna run away right now.
And I ran out of the way.
Wada, wada.
Foes spotted.
Firing on our foes.
I'm reloading.
Take this so long.
Foes here.
They're all heading to it.
Where is my team?
Where is Throwing grenade
Where are they?
I feel oh my god
Shield break is ready.
It's go time group I got my overshoot right here Soul armor
out getting hit.
Oh my god Oh my god, my last little armor.
Alright.
Shield breaker is mine.
Alright, let's go.
Oh shit!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, I hate this map!
I'm gonna let them go first actually.
let you guys go first just in case oh my work we're bearing
it we're bearing it up nice save I know thank you yeah I
know I was like oh fuck I thought I was fucked honestly I'm
on the fire spawns are almost locked we're getting into the
overtime stretch
soul armor here protect yourself
there I'm reloading okay casting soul armor let the darkness
take you that's why spawns locked I got the getting close
just two enemies left I got it
See this is what I have to do I just have to It's like I use
my teammates as diversion And then I just go the other way
Like literally I think that's the strat I have to just rush
it And use my teammates as diversion Okay so I'm right to
everybody Okay never mind Not everyone took it Yeah they
have to use it as bait It's literally Rainmaker.
Like, I'm literally playing that, like, Rainmaker, because
that's how I play, too.
Like, my teammates bait him in, and I go the other way.
Like, I'm literally using Splatoon strats.
I'm the use strategies from all different games that I play.
That's what I'm seeing.
It's like a combination of all different games type deal.
Like, how do I breach this?
I don't know how to breach this area.
Reloading Reloading My blades await my sight
Alright Alright
Alright I breached it
Jesus Christ Is there people behind me?
Like I said, the scat character is so strong
Distinguished Ready to bind death Nice.
Nice.
I got too cocky there.
That's fine.
He's not me.
I'm so dead.
Oh my god, I'm so dead.
Oh, I was sick though.
No, you got this!
Okay, these guys are good.
These guys are good.
No!
Holy shit Team, your bomb's been diffused These guys are
really good No more spawns team My dark spawn rises Okay
The con- Oh my god, the conqueror is so OP I think the eagle
is so OP in general It really is
The eagle is just too good, in general.
Oh my god, fucking worse.
Taking damage.
I don't know why I'm taking damage.
Are you serious?
Over here?
Holy fuck!
yeah no the scouting is so fast too i feel like the cooldown
for the scouting is like really fast
yeah this one this is like one or more frustrating part
i cannot respawn here
oh we can't yeah that's what i'm saying it's such a
What is that?
That was a tough raid team.
Let's do better.
That was hard.
This team is good.
We needed a concord.
Right team?
We need a concord like the scouters.
This time wisely.
Yeah.
No, it's been upgraded.
Get it if you need it.
Oh, debug?
Yeah, I was gonna say, why is it not working?
Concord, yeah.
Is it not how you pronounce it?
We need like the scouter.
I think the meta is nearly...
What's her name?
Mara and Concord.
And then that would be meta.
Yeah.
Condor is a condor okay sorry I think meta is Mara and
condor because like her her and her fucking eagle is just so
fast the like the cooldown is way too fast in general like
you see if she like fucking threw that 20 times she threw it
like so many times on me too
We're not getting the package.
Airdrop ready.
Grab it if you need it.
I feel like if the cooldown was, like, bigger it'd be
better, but, like, it's just, it's so difficult.
We're definitely evenly matched here, I think.
Give this to my teammates.
i always like forget which gun is on which i mean like keep
it consistent because i've been like um losing track on
where i should i hear them
see like that's so broken like really
that's so broken
all right oh if i don't move it doesn't oh okay sorry i've
been like i it's like whenever it happens it like freaks me
up nobody team shield break is ready grab it
okay yeah all right you stand still okay all right let's get
you know i'm riding out
Well, when I'm, like, locked in, I just, like...
Dynasty here.
I get, like, I want to shoot, you know?
Because there's, like, people literally in front of me.
It makes... I want to shoot him.
That's fine.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Just move to the other side, please.
Move to the other side!
Don't go!
Why would you go here?
Oh, my God.
Why?
Oh my god, why?
Just move to the other side!
You have the shield!
Oh my god, he's so stupid.
He has to go to the other side.
He doesn't have to follow me.
Oh, fuck, okay.
I don't know why he would.
Oh my god.
Like, why would you fight if you had the shield breaker?
You go to the other side.
Like, oh my god, that's so tilting.
That is so tilting.
Like, why would you fight?
Like, that's so stupid.
That's actually so stupid.
Like, like, you...
You bait...
Oh, my God.
Solo kill!
Like, it's so intuitive.
Throwing grenade.
Okay.
Oh my god, you own this.
That the souls of the fallen fortify you.
Ready to find death.
I'm reloading.
We're getting close.
Just two enemies left.
Darkspawn summoned.
I see him.
Alright.
The enemy has dropped the shield breaker.
They gave the...
The... Okay, maybe you smarter I don't know if you noticed
it but they gave the invisible one the sword what how did he
get here I
don't understand oh I wiped during overtime so it okay
why are you reviewing my position taking damage
reloading fuck oh my god I'm getting surrounded holy shit
the shotgun that's insane the shotgun is so
holy fuck the shotgun is so strong the shotgun is so strong
yeah i wish i had my art right now but i don't also have my
rocket good ass eagle I'm
casting soul armor.
Vanishing from ice.
I'm reloading.
Are you fucking- okay.
A fucking horse.
Let the souls of the fallen fortify you.
Purge to soul.
Grenade out!
Alright.
Holy fuck, this is intense.
Oh my god.
I didn't cover me!
Oh, I thought he covered me!
That sucks.
I just thought he covered me, he was covering me, but he
wasn't.
Oh my god.
I thought he was covering me.
That sucks.
I love you.
Really?
Please.
Oh my god, this...
Ah!
How are they not watching the bomb?
There were two of you!
there's two of you how are you not watching it this guy is
insane the condor guy is fucking crazy i'm not carrying this
i'm getting on by the condor you have to reload so much too
oh my god you have to reload so much yeah that was a tough
raid team let's do like literally i literally like i'm
frustrated because like um frustrated for that this is a
frustrating game um because like i thought he was with me
and then he walked away from me and i was like what were you
not with me like like i'm like what were you not with me it
is very frustrating yeah like i saw her next to me and then
he hard pushed me too pushing me and then i was just like
bro what the fuck like you were right beside me where did
you go
yeah but you want a better experience so you gotta play with
friends unless like i guess like i just have to start
calming with them but still grab that
i like the bear i like the movement with the bear
Grab that.
Actually, I feel like the cooldown is better.
Wait, what?
The Condor is just so strong.
When you don't have a Condor, it's such a hard game to play.
It's actually such a hard game to play if you don't have the
Scout.
How you doing, kid?
You fucking are gay.
It does so much.
Do I have a helmet?
No.
Buy that.
Yeah.
I'll take that.
Shieldbrokers forming at the throne room.
Marked it.
Keep forgetting that there's fall damage.
I can't get off the bear if I'm dropping down.
It's...
I might as well.
It's just a legendary.
I think it's a shitty gun, but it is a legendary.
Holy shit!
What the fuck?
Instantly!
Like, woolly...
like that's cool down that cool down is shit I fucking oh my
god my god
let me have the soul severed shit I need to try using this
chop and more
Oh I'm not playing very well my team is actually aim wise
they're good They're really good aim wise
Like they can these guys can aim but like Brain wise i don't
know we're getting into the overtime stretch
God fucking damn it They're using the ego.
They're using the drone.
Are you fucking crazy?
I'm riding out.
Listen up, group.
No more spawns.
We're an extra time.
Yeah.
Whoa.
Oh, fuck!
It's a lava here.
Protect yourself.
We're cornered.
Let my blades glide to victory!
I hear them.
It sucks because it's so scary.
Time's up.
Take this sonar.
Oh.
Get ready.
Siege tower coming in.
Oh my god.
Oh.
All right.
Oh, so that's what overtime is.
Oh, so you- they literally have to push.
Wait, that's so- That's so, like, I don't know.
So you have to push them.
Oh, that's so- Like, see, every game I'm learning something
new.
Like, you have to push them, or it doesn't mean anything.
Like, as defense.
If you just- You can't let them hold onto it.
You have to kill them.
Yeah.
I guess it's because they don't lose health.
I guess
So we fucked it up then let
What the fuck
It will all be over soon.
Take this soul armor.
It belongs
to me.
Soul
armor.
Alright.
Oh.
Charge planting.
Is that breachable?
I can't tell.
See, it's so fast.
The cooldown.
How does she have another fucking scad?
Holy shit.
Static.
is so tilting that shit is so broken how
does she have another one
that's crazy no this gun actually sucks no it does it's fast
but it sucks throwing grenade i have too many of you holes
now though i fucked up a little
oh my god i carried that oh shit i did it i carried that oh
no i did it oh the beginning was rough for me yeah i was i
was not doing so in the beginning but at least i carried in
the end They have, they have aim.
My team had aim.
I had brain.
They had aim.
I was literally finding all the breach spots for us.
I literally was like, okay, guys, we're going to go here.
I go breach this.
I breach that.
All right, we're all surrounding him.
I, no, they, they carried me by kills.
They literally killed everybody.
I like, I thought for us.
I'm thinking, me think.
Oh my God.
Oh, I breached so many walls for that.
Oh, my God.
We're a moment of Doki being the brains of the team.
Yeah, Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Holy shit.
Well, all right.
Final opinions about this game.
I'm not sponsored at all.
So, like, this is all from me.
Mara.
And Condor, strongest fucking characters in the game.
That bitch had like 20 scouts.
I swear to the guy.
Holy shit.
She was spamming that shit every time.
It feels crazy.
But these two are the strongest, I feel.
I don't know about the other.
I don't know which third character would go with them.
But...
Condor and Mara strongest in the game Yeah, and like the
Mara shields are so fucking OP If you're a solo queue
player, you have to play Mara Yeah, you have to play Mara
Because like there's no way you can stand still all the time
That's the worst part Because like you have to be like stand
still so you don't get detected But there's no way to stand
still like 24 7 And like especially if you're in a fucking
fight So it's so strong Scouts is so strong like the Eagles.
Other stuff it is not it is not casual friendly.
I will be blunt with all you guys.
It is not casual friendly.
It is very a lot to learn.
Like I even realized that when you get to like you can just
hold it's literally you can just hold onto the hold onto the
shield breaker if they don't push you.
And then you just get a free shield break.
Like it's just like that if you're like if you really just
want to play it really close you just hold on to it until
the end and i didn't realize you could i didn't realize that
was a thing um it's very esport like yeah it's very esport
like uh you have to if you for rank i don't think i think
rank wise it's gonna be very frustrating for a lot of people
it was very frustrating for me even with quick play um yeah
and very you have to find friends to play this if you want a
really really good time either that or you come in your
quick play game You come in your casual games, which is
something that a lot of casual players don't do.
So casual play, I feel like it's very geared towards people
who are looking for something more competitive.
It's like, like I said, I will make the comparison to the
finals.
The finals has a really big competitive, has a really big
competitive fan base, but the casual wise, it's very hard to
get into.
I've heard, it's similar with Rainbow Six Siege.
Rainbow prestige, very good competitive esport fan base, but
casual play is pretty much dead in Rainbow 16 because the
entry point is just way too high for a new player.
It's just so hard to learn for a new player.
But like right now, everyone is learning, but I can see that
in the future, when the meta gets more established and like
people, when the meta gets more established, people are
going to do more like fucked up stuff.
Like right now everyone's trying to figure out what the meta
is.
everyone's trying to figure out how to fucking play this
game um and it is free though it is free you can play it you
can check this game out yourself um and uh yeah i feel like
if you yeah honestly like um i'm gonna be curious if there's
gonna be sbmm for this because it really depends on your
teammates for this game because like if you're in apex
there's so many people playing so like It's fine if you're
like that dead and so look at it, but for this it's like
straight up 3v3 And like yeah, the professionals they're
gonna love this fucking game because it's super competitive
It's super competitive the gunplay is really nice.
I love the gunplay.
I think the gunplay and the movement Like you know like how
the crouch spam is like really slow But like when you figure
out the movement it's actually really fun And then the
gunplay is also really fun the worst part about the guns
There's not enough bullets.
I swear to god.
I feel like I'm always running have to reload when you're
reloading and you just look at the other player it's so
awkward it's
it's it's so awkward when we both ran out of ammo on both
guns and we just look at each other and it's so awkward um
because that has happened so many times where i was just i
look yeah i'll be like what do we do now
yeah I'm not used to using my melee yet so definitely
something I have to figure out as well because I'm not used
to using my melee at the moment um yeah the reloading dance
I've done that so many times the reloading dance there is a
melee I just it is I haven't used it because I'm it's just
the game is so intense and enjoy obviously during the fight
the fights last so long too like Like I said, sometimes the
TTK is so fast, and then sometimes the TTK is so low.
It really depends on where you're located.
If you're fighting in the base, the time to kill is so high,
because, like, you can bounce around everywhere.
But if you're fighting in the goddamn fucking forest, it's
so low, because, like, it's just, and you're dead because
there's no cover.
But in the houses, it's very high because you're just
bouncing everywhere.
um um there is like the thing yeah like it it's it's in it's
like high and low depending on where you're fucking situated
in the map um there is yeah but uh yeah but if you have all
three of them looking at you you're fucking dead basically
um what else can I say um we'll see how it goes for this
game i i want to be optimistic but like definitely jeff has
not played the solo queue experience for sure i will say
jeff has definitely played with friends when he gave his
review for this game as a solo i can tell a lot of pro
players are going to be like this game is so fun oh my god
you guys and then all of you is like whoa this game looks
really fun but the thing with that is that me giving a solo
queue experience shows you guys how fucking frustrating it
is as a you're playing by yourself because you know a lot of
the really big popular games um it has a casual fan base
because um it has a casual fan base because you can solo
queue even if you you know you have no one to play with you
can play by play it by yourself but like this game i don't
know a lot of pros a lot of like big streamers who have a
pre-made stack they're gonna be like this is so fun they're
gonna sell it really hard because they are having a lot of
fun when i had a teammate that actually was calming when
when you're when they're actually calming and like figuring
stuff out with them it was fun it was really fun i enjoyed
it but then the moment the moment i got thrown like the
moment i got thrown in games no one calms no one knows what
the fuck no one's calming um we're just figuring out as we
go along it was frustrating it was very frustrating because
this is a heavily team-reliant game is very team-reliant you
can't it's very hard to solo carry yeah
yeah and people were playing the event they were all
pre-stacked they're all pre-made so of course they're gonna
have a lot of fun but yeah like if you're trying to check
this game out you're gonna have a lot of fun with friends
you're gonna have a lot of fun with a three stack or even a
duo duo three stack you're gonna have a lot of fun fuck the
random guy third guy who cares um If you're solo cute, good
luck.
It's a Gamba.
Good fucking luck if you're solo cute.
Because it will be the most frustrating experience of your
life.
Like, it will be very frustrating.
I will say, I am impressed with how optimized this game is.
it is 20 gigabytes and other than the fucking fight in the
first game other than the fucking fight in the first game
where like i for some reason lagged or some shit um it is 20
it is what 18 gigabytes it's 18 gigabytes and a lot of
people time to complain that it's poorly optimized it's 18
gigabytes though that's the thing i i don't want get why how
it how is it poorly optimized it's the file it's 18
gigabytes and um and like for me it ran pretty well for me
it's like but like it ran pretty well for me oh i am on 50
90 sorry guys i forgot i do have streamer privilege i
I forgot, guys.
Don't worry.
I'm, I forgot, guys.
I'm still one of you guys.
I'm still the people.
I almost forgot.
I do run a 5090.
It's very optimized for me with my 50.
All right.
Okay.
I don't know how it was.
Yeah.
I do.
I will have to be up front.
I do have a 5090.
So it's very well optimized with me.
Um, I'm in the one.
So I guess like, I don't know.
I don't know what the RAM and GPU situation is for this
game.
But I don't know like which one, which for people, like how
bad it is for people with lower graphics.
But I'm playing on medium, by the way.
I'm playing on medium.
I'm not playing on high.
I did play the first game, first couple of games on high
just to see what the graphics are like.
And I swapped the medium.
Obviously the pro players are going to play on low all the
time.
But I still, you know, see how pretty the game looks like at
least um you privileged i forgot i mean yeah i've been
thinking with super chat thank you thank you um um i don't
know i guess like if people are complaining about
optimization then i guess like you know it is what it then
it then it's not very well optimized because like for me i
was like oh it's 18 gigabytes and like everything seems fine
on my but then I do have a 5090 so um I do have the streamer
privilege I I do have the streamer privilege but if you guys
say it actually isn't very well optimized I believe you guys
um because like you know the general public don't have
access not have it 5090 but this is my job so um this is my
job so like I do have to have a good GPU because I play a
lot of video games but I guess I bought the 5090 before
prices went up, by the way, so thank fucking God.
Like, I literally dodged a bullet.
I bought RAM and my 5090 before AI got really bad.
I was very lucky in that department.
But I will believe you guys if...
I believe you guys, if you did say it's like...
People are saying it's not very optimized.
um and um yeah oh i've got s rank in splatoon before i've
done it before if you're doing like can you add getting s
rank i've done i've got s rank in splatoon one two and three
um um and that's why i was like i knew the strats for this
game regarding fucking rainmaker i hate rainmaker i hate
that game mode with passion um but literally it's like you
bait your teammates go left you go with your teammates to
left bait all the people on the left side and then you run
right side That's literally it.
That's literally the Rainmaker strat.
So that's what, like, I was like, guys, come on.
Go.
Right side.
Leave me.
Don't fight with me.
Run.
Um, uh, thank you for the raid, Eva.
Thank you.
So it's like lots of, so you need to know how to use.
It's like Valorant Strats, Rainbow Six Siege Strats, uh,
Splatoon Strats, Apex Gunplay.
It's like a combination of everything.
So that's my opinion.
Will I play this game again?
Not solo queue.
I will be frank with you guys.
I will not play this game solo queue.
It's way too frustrating.
Like I'm playing with you guys watching.
It's fine.
But I think off stream.
I will not play this off stream by myself.
Only because it's just way too frustrating playing it solo
queue.
If I play it off stream.
because there's just so much stuff you need to know like you
need to be able to coordinate with your team because if one
person is a fucking dead weight it's over it's like yeah
it's and then like i think calming and stuff calming your
teammates up we're like they're preaching this way and stuff
like that and be like coordinate alts and everything um yeah
that's that's my honest hope this game doesn't die like
concord um that would really suck but top i can tell rank
wise top 500 oh man i don't even know if i can find a
fucking pre-maid that would play with me to grind i think
like the pre-maids they'll be stuck there forever like
they'll the pre-maids for this like it's just like they'll
play together and that's the only people they play with i
feel like unless they're trying to grind for rank one um but
definitely for this game i don't see a lot of people
branching out from outside they're already established stack
especially if they're grinding in rank two because of how
yeah the like i feel like the top 500 grind for this game is
gonna be super intense i will be curious if this game will
be popular in a only because like Rainbow Six Siege itself
is not very popular in Asia it's very popular in EU and NA
but like I don't think this game could be strong in the Asia
market only because Siege itself isn't strong but Valorant
is strong yeah Valorant is strong in in Asia so depends
because there's Apex, and Siege.
So, Siege is not strong.
Valorant and Apex is strong in Asia.
But I don't know.
I honestly don't know if the...
Don't know.
It'll be...
We'll see.
We'll see how it goes.
We'll just see how it goes.
Anyway, guys.
I hope you guys had a fun time watching getting a glimpse
into...
Yeah, Splatoon is strong.
But Splatoon...
People also really love how cute Splatoon is.
um anyway that's my opinion on this game um as the solo
queue player i feel like the other streamers the other pros
they do give a different experience with a stack and it
might it definitely does look a lot fun in a stack in
general like i'm pretty sure the people in the stacks are
winning every fucking game they're fucking playing right now
um but this is my opinion as someone that
Yeah, it is.
Yeah, like, three stack, very fun.
Honestly, I think it'll be very fucking fun.
You'll enjoy it a lot with your friends because it's very
competitive.
You're a very competitive player.
You'll very much enjoy this.
If you're a casual player, good luck because it punishes you
hard.
Like, I think I bumped into some...
You can see how, like, the casual players I bumped into.
I bumped into casual players on there and I literally just
gunned them down.
like um yeah i feel like i feel like you like you'll if
you're a casual player it's going to be very rough for you
in general especially if you're by yourself yeah anyway guys
that's my opinion that's my final say on this um thank you
all for watching it was very interesting checking out
haggard it was very interesting being like the only five
people queuing again and again and again like i don't even
know how many times i fucking didn't get a game for the
longest time i think it was like seven times i was just like
please just get me in i just won a fucking game i don't
understand um that was crazy i i couldn't believe it but
yeah as always like every match i learned something new and
i got better taking in the information but as always
everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move around
to get that blood flowing and you used there for me head to
bed cause you deserve it thank you all for coming to today's
stream thank you all over the subscriptions um the super
chats um the raids i really appreciate guys and i hope you
guys enjoyed like my review of this game like i said if i
play this game again definitely not by myself because i
would fucking punch my punch my monitor um i'll be frank
with you guys if i have to play this off stream by myself i
will punch my monitor i was fucking crashing out at some
points um Hey guys, bye everybody.
Bye-bye.